Guten Morgen Linus. Guten Morgen Markus. Es gibt eine Schutzlücke im Kampf gegen den Terror. Wo denn? Kinder.
Netzpolitik mit der Folge zweihundertvierundneunzig vom.
Zweiten oder dritten April, wir wissen noch nicht genau, wann wir veröffentlichen, aber aufgenommen am zweiten April und im Studio zu Gast,
Markus Reuter von Netzpolitik Punkt org, der ja auch schon zum wievielten Mal im Lokbuch zu Gast ist.
Zwei, drei, vier Mal, ich weiß nicht genau. Ich habe mich mal als Tim verkleidet hier.
Ein Reguler. Oh, das hast du jetzt, das hast du das erste Mal, dass es zugegeben wurde. Genau, Markus war, das war glaube ich sogar dein erster Auftritt im Logbuch. Ähm als Tim nicht konnte.
Und da haben wir haben wir dich einfach als äh Pim Tridlov, glaube ich, auftreten la.
Ja, das waren, das waren noch die die lustigen alten Zeiten, da hatten wir noch lustige Meldungen. Ähm inzwisch.
Damals hat das Internet noch gut war.
Damals als man den Internet noch alles sagen durfte.
Ähm wir machen heute eine Sendung garantiert ohne Uploadfilter, also als Thema, das Thema wird einfach nicht erwähnt, weil es hat einfach das Logbuch,
Ohne es gab einfach lange kein Blogbuch mehr ohne und deswegen machen wir heute garantiert ohne Uploadfilter. Dafür aber mit Feedback. Ich fange.
An, wir haben weil wir es letzten Sendungen nicht so besprochen haben, gibt es, das ist jetzt glaube ich größtenteils oft die LMP zweihundert,
zweiundneunzig bezieht sich dieses Feedback, also nicht die zweihundertdreiundneunzig, wo wir mit Julia Reder nochmal gesprochen haben, sondern die Sendung davor. Dazu kommentiert AD oder Ad. Ich weiß ja immer noch nicht, wie man's ausspricht.
Eine Sache habe ich übrigens nicht verstanden. Warum glauben die Lobbyisten, dass man mit der Richtlinie Druck auf YouTube ausüben kann? Lizenzverhandlungen, ach scheiße, ist ja trotzdem wieder Upl.
Es ist ablauffit. Zack.
Lizenzverhandlungen mit besseren Konditionen abzuschließen. Eigentlich erfüllt die Plattform die neuen Bedingungen für den Haftungsausschuss schon jetzt. Best
F hat bei der Lizenzierung kaum jemand hat mehr Beziehungen zu Urwahlrechtsindustrie und das bisherige Beteiligungsmodell kann vermutlich,
in einen Preis für eine Lizenz umgerechnet werden. Heißt Dennitz. Niemand hat bessere Filtertechnik für Audio und Video. Sie definieren den höchsten Industriestandard. Es sind alle, die dorthin aufschließen müssen,
Drittens, Notes in Takedown gib.
Kaum ein Anreiz entgegenkommender zu sein, oder? Und wenn YouTube glaubt einem Haftungsrisiko ausgesetzt zu sein, kann dieses durch Lizenzvereinbarungen durch höchstens abgemildert oder eben nicht ausgeschlossen werden. Es ist in dem Fall durchaus möglich,
dass sie die bisherigen Inhalte aus EU-Ländern aus der Verbreitung nehmen, die freie Nutzung für alle EU-Internetnutzer einstellen und nur noch mit den bestehenden großen Kanälen arbeiten, was vermutlich sowieso ein Großteil ihres Marktes ausmacht,
dann werden sie überhaupt nicht mehr von dem Artikel erfasst.
Und dann haben sie noch weniger Anreizlizenzen zu vereinbaren. Wenn die Preise nicht möglichst niedrig sind. Ja, genauer.
Da freut sich der kleine Urheber.
Freut sich der kleine Urheber, ja? Ähm!
Ich denke schöner und knapper kann man die das Problem einfach auch gar nicht zusammenfassen, das hier wieder ähm versucht wird den Großen irgendwie eins auszuwischen. Das geht halt beim Mark,
beherrschenden Teilnehmern einfach nicht mehr, weil die eben alle Auflagen, die man ihnen geben könnte mit,
also problemlos erfüllen und eben auch einen viel krasseren Hebel haben, wenn sie sagen, ja gut, dann lizenzieren wir eben nicht, ne? Genauso beim Leistungsschutzrecht, äh wo ja auch im Prinzip,
der gleiche Effekt ist, dass er sagt so, ja gut, dann machen wir das eben nicht.
Ja, ich meine, das sieht man jetzt auch gerade, wie äh Facebook jetzt ja auch äh,
Zuckerberg irgendwie sagt, ja wir wir wollen jetzt Regulierung, mach doch mal die Datenschutzgrundverordnung für alle, weil wir bis jetzt implementiert, die könnte mit umgehen und können im Zweifelsfall dann eben,
damit die Mitbewerber noch weiter aus dem Markt kegeln, also das sind.
Wir wollten nicht über dieses Thema reden, also nicht über die die Uploadfilter.
Ich habe das, ich habe das vergessen, ist alles, ist alles Upload-Filter, das gesamte Feedback ist Uploadfilter, sorry.
Falsche Versprechungen am Anfang, ja.
Ähm ein ein relativ langes Feedback von Arne, wo ich mir mal kurz die Möglichkeit nehme, das etwas zu kürzen. Ähm und zwar ähm,
Der Linus sich ein wenig Sorgen macht, wie die,
jüngeren mit dem Problem umgehen, dachte ich mir, ein Anschauungsbeispiel zu liefern. Ich bin zwar in meinen Zwanzigern und dementsprechend dabei, den Jüngeren zu entwachsen, behaupte aber mal zumindest noch nah genug dran zu sein.
Ähm,
Ich habe sie, dass ein wenig das Vertrauen in die Implementation unseres politischen Systems verloren. Nicht, dass die Ideen dahinter keine guten wären, aber es scheint immer häufiger eher schlechte
Outputs zu gener,
wenn die Abstimmung aus anders ausgegangen wäre, wäre die Enttäuschung in unsere Systeme sicherlich nicht so stark ausgeprägt, aber das Problem ist grundsätzlicher, als diese eine Abstimmung. Rund jedes zweite Jahr kommt die EU mit irgendeinem neuen Quatsch aus den geheimen Verhandlungen.
Vor Ortsdatenspeicherung TTIP Urheberrechtsnovelle, um nur ein paar zu nennen und bei der EU zu bleiben. Das Ganze fühlt sich ja eher
Arbeit an, anstatt nach einer Vertretung der Interessen der Bürger, die manchmal Missbrauch und der Korrekturbedarf. Letzteres wäre meine Hoffnung an ein System.
Natürlich hat's jetzt ziemlich jedes Thema zwei oder mehr Seiten und man kann seine eigenen Ansichten nicht immer durchsetzen, aber zumindest ein vernünftiges Verhalten gegenüber Bürgern mit einwenden, wäre doch nicht zu viel verlangt,
oder vielleicht,
könnte sie ein, ja sogar überzeugen. Stattdessen habe ich während der gesamten Geschichte um die Uhrhörigsowelle einmal mehr erlebt. Erstens, die Mehrheit der Politiker fühlt sich offensichtlich von einem patizierenden Bürger gestocht. Vor allem, wenn der eine andere Meinung hat,
Zweitens, Interessen weniger gut vernetzter Lobbyisten und ihrer Geldgeber zählen zu zählen viel mehr als selbst unentkräftete Einwände,
Drittens, es wird sich noch nicht einmal mit Themen auseinandergesetzt oder Leute dafür beschäftigt? Zum Beispiel wird Machbarkeit äh juristisch gelöst,
real betrachtet. Viertens, Führungspolitiker sprechen Teil der Bürger wahlweise das Menschsein ab, die Fähigkeit, die Meinung frei zu bilden,
oder und das ist ja noch vergleichsweise harmlos. Sie werden verleumdet als gekauft, fremdgesteuert und Gefahr für die Demokratie.
Kriminelle Maschinerie halt, ne? Also fünftens.
Unsere vierte Gewaltbliss großteilig ins gleiche Horn. Anstatt die Story solche Hohlköpfe versuchen mit dreisten Lügen die Öffentlichkeit zu täuschen, zu schreiben.
Auch ich könnte darüber konnte darüber lachen, wenn sie sich in den Augen der Netzöffentlichkeit mal wieder blamierten, aber eigentlich ist das Ganze nicht witzig und dies war wieder mal das oben beschriebene Verhalten dem äh.
Moment und dieses Mal war das oben beschriebene Verhalten, dem Vertreter Teilen des Souveräns gegenüber besonders ausgeprägt. Ähm.
Springen wollen, ich überspringe mal ein bisschen was, nun kommt die nächste Wahl und die Frage, was man wählen soll. Und ich hoffe, eine Vernunftwahl nach den meisten Übereinstimmungen für mich.
Wäre das die Linke.
Ansonsten eine richtige Protestwahl klammern Wahl zu ungültig oder Partei zu treffen. Allerdings kenne ich auch,
den von Mal zu Mal von Gesetzesvorlage oder zu Gesetzesvorlage immer stärker werdenden Impuls, eine Wahl geboren aus reiner Ablehnung des ganzen Systems in seiner jetzigen,
implementation zu treffen. Das wäre die AfD. Über diesen Impuls habe ich mit einigen meiner politisierten Bekannten gesprochen und er war in erstaunlicherweise nicht fremd,
Nun habe ich mit den Thesen der AfD äh alles in allem zwei herzlich wenig am Hut. Aber es scheint mir momentan die einzige Wahl zu sein.
Wenn man den anderen Parteien einen Denkzettel geben will, der auch ankommt.
Geschichte, die die AfD als narrativ gut findet. Ich mir kommt, ich weiß nicht, ich äh kennst du diesen Arne?
Nö, also ich weiß es nicht. Ich hab.
Also es ist so, dass mir kommt das sehr bekannt vor dieses Muster. Ich bin ja eigentlich Linken Wähler, aber jetzt bleibt mir die einzige Möglichkeit äh ist jetzt die AfD zu wählen. Äh das ist ja.
Also er er schreibt ja auf jeden Fall auch, dass er diesem Impuls nicht nachgeben wird und äh will aber nur sagen, dass es eben.
Die das ist das selbst er, das merkt dem den Impuls zu haben, ja? Und tja, wie wie sie,
Das ist genau, das ist die Sorge. Wir können natürlich nur hoffen, dass das entsprechend hm, dass sie dem Impuls nicht stattgebt, ja?
Ja, ich meine, die AfD hat ja alles getan, äh quasi dem eigene Seiten für Uploadfilter und so gemacht, ne? Und versuchen natürlich, sich da jetzt draufzusetzen. Das Ganze,
quasi den EU-Frust, der da durchaus entstanden sein könnte ähm irgendwie zu nutzen und dann halt in ihr rechtspopulistisches,
Ding zu gießen. Die werden keine besseren Netzpolitik machen und das kann man jeder Stelle sagen, die haben erstens keine fähigen Leute dafür, und zweitens sind sie halt eine rechtsradikale Partei, äh die am Ende immer sagt
die Ausländer haben das Internet kaputt gemacht, ne? Oder die EU oder das ist das da kommt nichts bei rum außer antidemokratratischen Scheiß.
Ja, wenn man, also wenn man Idioten wählt, das kann man sich gerade in Großbritannien anschauen, das ist ja ein Thema, was also boah, hoffentlich, hoffentlich haben wir nicht auch noch irgendwie solche Spinner und ich würd noch 'n bisschen widersprechen,
Also es war nicht alles schlecht in der Europäischen Union. Ja ähm natürlich, das ist jetzt mal wieder so ein ein.
Ein Beispiel aber viele Sachen, die aus der Europäischen Union.
Ich würde sogar noch weitergehen. Ich glaube, ich glaube, dass diese Protestbewegung, das hatte ich auch normal in einem Kommentar auf Netzpolitik auch geschrieben äh
Sie hat eigentlich auch gewonnen, weil die gezeigt hat, hey, guck mal, wir können in Brüssel ansetzen, wir können irgendwie ganz schön Druck und Stress machen, wenn wir uns verbünden, wenn wir irgendwie auf die Straße gehen, wenn wir irgendwie,
coole Online-Kampagnen, die auch aggressiv angehen. Ähm,
da ist ja Bewegung drin gewesen, die haben ja hier rumgerudert, am Ende ist die ganze SPD dagegen gestimmt. Sie es war ja, da war ja Musik drin. Und ich finde, diese Erfahrung ist eine positive und ich finde, äh,
daraus kann man eher lernen, hey, in Zukunft müssen wir halt noch früher daran gehen und noch mehr äh Ärger machen und dann kann man das auch noch drehen, also ich meine,
Ich glaube, dass die ganze, diese ganze
Uploadfiltergeschichte, wir reden jetzt da tatsächlich doch nochmal drüber. Wäre, wenn das übergesprungen wäre, nicht nur nach Österreich, was passiert ist und nicht nur ein bisschen nach Polen, sondern noch weiter, dann wäre das äh Kipper gewesen. Also das war ja eigentlich,
nicht so weit davon entfernt, diese diese politische Auseinandersetzung auf der Straße zu gewinnen. Also ich sehe das nicht alles so negativ und ich glaube, das,
hilft nicht zu sagen, die EU ist Schuld, weil am Ende sind die Leute das Schuld, die dafür abgestimmt haben.
Genau und die, von denen kennen wir die Namen. Da haben wir Listen.
Names in the Dressus. Nein, da, die kann man abbilden, ne? Also ohne die AfD zu wä.
Axel Voss abzuwählen wird schwierig, aber ähm wäre auf jeden Fall wünschenswert. Und irgendwann werden wir auch den loswerden,
Lennard äh schreibt Feedback. Ich hatte mich ja ein bisschen darüber geäußert, dass ich im Prinzip,
diese diesen Ruf habe, Zensur, Filter und so ein bisschen ähm über das Ziel hinaus bewerte
Und äh sogar so weit gehen würde zu befürchten, dass es unter Umständen den Protest auch ein bisschen nicht unbedingt geholfen hat,
ähm da mit einer, mit einer Vereinfachung
in der Form aufzutreten. Da schreibt Lennart zu, kleines Feedback zu deiner Kritik am Zensurbegriff. Ich kann dein Ansinnen verstehen und teile es grundsätzlich,
dass wir schon die sachlich besseren Argumente haben und deswegen nicht auf inhaltliche,
Kürzungen angewiesen sind, die wiederum nur die Angriffsfläche für den politischen Gegner erhöhen. Aber erstens in diesem Fall gibt es klare Hinweise darauf, dass der politische Gegner so sehr in im faktenlehren Raum operiert,
dass es vielleicht sogar ein bisschen egal ist, ob wir auch verkürzen. Na ja, zweitens.
Du liegst mit deiner Kritik am Begriff der Zensur falsch. Nicht nur staatliche Zensur ist Zensur, Artikel fünf.
Eins, Absatz zwei Grundgesetz umfasst nur Vorzensur, sogenannte Nachzensur oder Zensur im weitesten Sinne, die dann auch äh nicht staatliche Akteure umfasst,
nicht davon umfasst. Der Begriff Zensur im allgemeinen Sinne ist also deutlich weiter als der Begriff der Zensur aus Artikel fünf. Der Begriff wird hier,
natürlich negativ konnotiert verwandt, aber es steht nicht auf den Schildern, dass es Zensuren deswegen einer Artikel,
äh eine Verletzung von Artikel fünf Grundgesetz hinzukommt. Es finden sich hier,
aber sogar eine vorab Auswahl anhand von bestimmten Kriterien. Anstatt einer begrüßenswerten Nachzensur, die eben Notes and Takedown,
wäre in diesem Fall also eine Vorzensur. Diese,
ist auch ganz explizit durch den Staat angeordnet. Zensur ist im Sinne des Artikel fünf Grundgesetz, die Prüfung des Inhalts einer Äußerung vor deren Verbreitung.
Ähm,
So unglaublich durch den Start vor deren Verbreitung durch den Staat so unglaublich abwegig ist die Idee, es handelte sich hier nur um Zensur im Sinne von durch den Staat äh.
Ist diese Idee also gar nicht. Hm, also.
Kann man es auch anders meinen und zweitens wäre es für einen Laien, selbst die Behauptung, es handele sich hier um staatliche Zensur für mich immer noch recht akzeptabel.
Somit du schießt mit deiner Kritik etwas über das Ziel hinaus.
Ja, schwierige Frage. Ähm ich na ja, also ich ich sehe eher, dass dass man eben solche Strukturen und Infrastrukturen etabliert und wie man jetzt an der,
Terrorrichtlinie der EU sieht, äh, gibt's halt sofort irgendwie den nächsten, die ruft. So ein Uploadfilter, das wäre auch für uns praktisch und das wird halt weitergehen, ne? Also ich glaube, dass wir da also,
damit.
Aber ich würde Lennard entgegnen dieser Filter.
Wird ja nicht gesagt, äh lass uns einen Zensurfilter für Urheberrechtsverstöße machen oder so, sondern die, dieser Filter wird ja damit argumentiert, okay,
findet ein ein Rechteverstoß statt und das ist ja so. Ja? Und ähm,
Genauso würde ein Terrorfilter haben wir jetzt gerade mit äh Christchurch natürlich wieder das das Thema auch relativ präsent in den Medien. Niemand würde sagen.
Ähm wenn wenn ich jetzt eine eine glatte Urheberrechtsverletzung begehe. Ja, ich ich nehme ein
Lied eines bekannten Interpreten oder einer Sängerin und Laters auf YouTube hoch und macht da irgendwie Monetarisierung mit und bereichere mich daran äh und dann wird das runtergenommen, würde niemand sagen, oh Zensur.
Und deswegen war dieses Argument nicht sinnvoll. Genauso würde auch niemand äh hat auch niemand Zensur geschrien als Facebook irgendwie millionenfach,
eben diesen diesen diese Christchurch Aufzeichnung des Streams dort gelöscht hat. Und das ist der der Punkt mit Zensur und das ist uns auch damals schon,
Die Älteren von euch werden sich erinnern, als wir in ähm Deutschland diskutiert haben Netzsperren,
ähm also damals primär von Ursula von der Leyen ins Letzt ins Netz geführt, ins Feld geführt. Ähm,
mit dem Argument äh ähm dokumentierten Kindesmissbrauch. Im Prinzip den Zugriff auf Server per DNS zu unterbinden, wo so etwas stattfindet, was natürlich relativ weit an der Realität vorbei ging, weil sowas,
nicht im normalen Internet über DNS-Server abrufbar ist, sondern eher
im Darknet oder sowas stattfindet. Ähm da wurde auch ne, Stichwort Zensursola, dieser Protest und es lief auch, das war auch schwer zu erklären, dass man mit Zinsen, mit dem Argument der Zensur.
Gegen ähm das ja doch relativ here Ziel den Zugriff auf dokumentierten Kindesmissbrauch äh einzuschränken vorgeht.
Und damals war eben das Motto löschen statt sperren.
Genau. Ähm im Prinzip.
Geil genau. Ja.
Okay, also hier eine eine andere Zensurdefinition von.
Wobei ich noch eine eine Geschichte natürlich daran, also äh grundsätzlich ist halt Zensur eine staatliche Sache. Wir geraten aber,
durch diese Infrastrukturen in privater Hand, die so groß sind, dass sie in der Öffentlichkeit darstellen oder ein öffentliches Gut eigentlich schon sind, geraten wir in, in so komischer Graubereiche, in denen man eben auch
da schon von Zensur reden könnte oder darüber auf jeden Fall reden muss, wie ob der Zensurbegriff auf diesem klassischen, da sitzt
staatliche Zensor in der Zeitung und schneidet irgendwas aus. Ob das auf die modernen digitalen Infrastrukturen und Monopole übertragbar ist. Also die Diskussion finde ich spannend, habe leider noch sehr wenig äh coole Sachen dazu,
gewesen, wo immer das mal definiert und sagt, okay, hören wir dann, was ist denn private Zensur oder ist das schon öffentlich und so, aber okay, führt ein bisschen weg.
Dann haben wir Feedback von Erik,
Ähm Eriks Feedback kame von mehreren Leuten, auch per E-Mail und Kommentar ähm zu der Unterscheidung von Sensitivität und Spezifität,
Ähm,
die Sensitivität auch Recall genannt, hast du meiner Ansicht nach richtig erklärt. Es handelt sich um die Wahrscheinlichkeit, mit der ein Fall, zum Beispiel der Fall Urheberrechtsverletzung vorhanden, richtigerweise als solcher erkannt wurde.
Bei der Spezifität hast du
meiner Meinung nach einen Fehler gemacht. Die Spezifität ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, mit der die Abwesenheit eines zu erkennenden Falls, zum Beispiel
keine Urheberrechtsverletzung vorhanden. Richtigerweise,
als solche erkannt wurde. Aufgrund deiner Formulierung habe ich die Vermutung, dass du nicht auf die Spezifität, sondern auf den positiven Vorhersagewert Englisch die Precision,
hinaus wollte. Der positive Vorhersagewert ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, mit der ein erkannter Fall, zum Beispiel Urheberrechtsverletzungen erkannt, auch wirklich ein solcher Fall ist,
Also Urheberrechtsverletzungen vorhanden, das ist auch das, was ich erklärt habe, das ist auch das, was ich meinte. Und äh wenn das jetzt bei Erik auf einmal äh positiver Vorherseher Wert heißt, dann ist es das, was ich meinte. Da sieht man.
Ne, so eine abgebrochene Wissenschaftlerkarriere äh äh die äh hat dann stellt man dann auch im Detail fest, das ist vielleicht gar nicht,
falsch war, dass ich da nicht an der Uni geblieben bin. Zur Vollständigkeit möchte ich hier nochmal den negativen Vorhersagewert erwähnen. Das ist dann eben die Wahrscheinlichkeit, mit der die erkannte Abwesenheit eines Falles keine Urheberrechtsverletzung. Er,
ein solcher Fall ist, keine Urheberrechtsverletzung vorhanden. Danke Erik, ich bin froh, dass wir auch im wissenschaftlichen Umfeld gehört werden, trotz unserer.
Ähm bildungsfernen Sozialisationen, die zu zu derartigen Fehlern führt und deswegen danke für die,
Klarstellung. Dann haben wir noch einen Kommentar von.
Das war's schon. Das war schon. Das war's. Kein weiterer Kommentar? Habe ich jetzt alle Kommentare vorgelesen? Wahnsinn. Dann kommen wir jetzt auch schon zum ersten Thema. Markus, es gibt eine Schutzlücke. Du hast es gerade schon gesagt. Die Schutzlücke sind.
Ja, das sind die Schuhzucker sind eindeutig, diese terroristischen Kinder, die hier ständig uns mit Anschlägen bedrohen. Das ist ja zumindest die Argumentationslinie äh des Innenministeriums äh.
Ich fürchte mich ja auch vor Kindern.
Zu dem Maße. Zum Glück sind die so laut, dass man von weitem hört, wenn sie kommen. Aber wenn sich mal ab und zu so ein Kind an einen Rand schleicht, das ist auch echt ein Problem,
Worum geht's? Netzpolitik Org hat mal wieder einen äh Text im Volltext veröffentlicht und zwar geht es um den Trojanereinsatz.
Von Geheimdiensten. Es ist ein Gesetzentwurf des Innenministeriums zu harmonisierung, des Verfassungsschutzrechts. Harmonisierung ist ja auch echt so ein, also.
Ja, das ist ja der.
Das gute die die guten Gesetze harmonisieren. Äh äh also die die Sprache, das ist interessant äh das Framing, wie die wie die wie die ganzen Ministerien, das gute Kita-Gesetz und das, also es sind alles jetzt alles immer, das klingt alles so gut.
Wir sind ja auch alle sehr harmoniebedürftig, insofern freuen wir uns ja über Harmonisierungsgesetze, ne.
Ja und wenn zu Harmonie halt gehört, dass man Kinder jetzt auch überwacht, äh dann also die Grenze bisher war bei wie viel Jahren war die jetzt vierzehn? Und jetzt muss man an diese Terrorkinder ran.
Terrorkinder. Was machen wir, wenn wenn jemand jünger ist und und auch.
Genau, also das war hat ja so die Debatte um dieses Thema so ein bisschen bestimmt diese Kinder. Dabei ist so dieser Staatsrojaner ein bisschen unter den Tisch gefallen, ne?
Der Staatsräder ist eigentlich das viel größere Thema, deswegen gehen wir da auch eher darauf ein. Ähm nur nochmal äh weil.
Staatstrojaner ist ja immer so ein wiederkehrendes Thema. Ich habe jetzt gesehen, im Prinzip seit äh das letzte Mal war's groß vor zwei Jahren. Da wurde nämlich der äh
die Quellen, Telekommunikationsüberwachung für die Polizei auch in Alltagskriminalfällen erlaubt. Ähm
Dazu muss ich mal kurz zwei Begriffe nochmal wiederholen. Es wird im Prinzip in dieser Trojanerdebatte unterschieden,
die online Durchsuchung, also die komplette Durchsuchung des Computers im Prinzip fernforensik, ja? Also wir gucken alles was da, wir können auf alles zugreifen, was auf diesem Rechner ist und alles was dieser Rechner an.
Digitalen Spuren enthält, wird forensisch ausgewertet.
Und davon ab äh abzugrenzen. Die Quellen, Telekommunikationsüberwachung, die im Prinzip als Fiktion daher kommt, dass man sagt, okay,
der Computer ist ein Kommunikationsgerät, da darüber wird geskyped oder sonst was oder gechattet, dieser Chat findet in irgendeiner Form verschlüsselt statt oder die verschicken irgendwelche E-Mails über Server, die wir nicht abhören können,
und jetzt greifen wir die Telekommunikation an der Quelle ab. Ähm,
Und das bedeutet natürlich, so zumindest fickt in dieser juristischen Idee ist die Eingriffstiefe und auch die Argumentation eine andere bei einer Quellentelekommunikationsüberwachung als bei einer Online Online-Durchsuchung.
Und äh.
Jetzt streiten sich natürlich die Expertinnen und Experten darüber, ob diese Quellen TKÜ-Technisch in der Form überhaupt machbar ist, weil ja trotzdem eine Schwachstelle auf dem System ausgenutzt wird, weil trotzdem ein Zugriff auf das System ähm.
Stattfindet und weil es vor allem in der Vergangenheit mit dem Staatstrojaner, mit der Stadtstranalyse des CC zweitausendelf war das, glaube ich, oder zweitausendzehn,
auch gezeigt wurde, dass diese technische Umsetzung der Idee,
Quellen Telekommunikationsüberwachung gar nicht so möglich war oder zumindest nicht so implementiert wurde, wie sich die Juristen,
und die die Gesetzgeber gedacht haben, nämlich da wurden dann einfach Screenshots auf dem System gemacht, da wurde das Mikrofon abgehört,
In dem Fall, wo du das Mikrofon anmachst, an so einem Computer,
Das ist in der einen Situation eine eine Quellentelekommunikationsüberwachung und in der nächsten Situation ist das die Verwandlung des Wohnraums. Je nachdem,
Zeitpunkt wo dieses Mikrofon anmacht und da gibt's eben juristische Unterschiede, die sich technisch relativ schwer abbilden lassen. Ähm,
Das ist aber relativ egal, weil diese Unterscheidung ähm nur für die Polizei eine Rolle spielt. In dem Fall also ähm,
Die Quellentelekommunikationsüberwachung wurde in Alltags mehr oder weniger Alltagsfällen dann auch erlaubt. Vorher nur für schwere Kriminalität, die online Durchsuchung nicht. Also Polizei darf euer Smartphone hängen, um WhatsApp abzuhören, darf aber nicht euer Smartphone hacken, um.
Die Dateien alle anzuschauen.
Um alle Dateien anzuschauen. Ja, da äh da brauchen sie eine andere,
brauchst ein anderes Gesetz für und das wird heute in dieser Sendung auch noch öfter eine Rolle spielen, je nachdem welches äh welcher Verdacht besteht, sind auch andere Instrumente erlaubt. Und das war damals hier in diesem,
Gesetzgebungsprozess, wo ich eben auch als Sachverständiger für den Kaus Computerclub vertreten war. Das Thema zu sagen, okay, wir nehmen diese.
Diese Instrumente, die wir vorher nur für schwerste Kriminalität erlaubt haben und sagen, jetzt könnte er das auch noch,
machen bei was weiß ich, falsch paar. Nee, falsch parken, was nicht, aber irgendwie Besitz von Drogen oder sonstigen, ne? Also irgendwie Dinge, wo man jetzt nicht,
unbedingt automatisch viele Jahre für den Knast geht.
Jetzt gibt's also diesen Gesetzesentwurf des Innenministeriums, äh, Innenministerium übersetzt, wie ihr wisst in Horst Seehofer und wenn Horst Seehofer irgendetwas harmonisieren möchte, dann ähm ist allen k.
Sollten wir alle Alarmglocken mit Leuten.
Sagen sie möchten sowohl dem Inlandsgeheimnis als auch dem Auslandsgeheimnis? Auch das muss man nochmal erklären. Inlandsgeheimnis ist in Deutschland das Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz.
Die wie muss man sich denn Aufgabe vorstellen, also außer jetzt halt dem dem ideellen und finanziellen Unterstützung von rechtsradikalen Terrorgruppen.
Na ja, ist die, die quasi in die Abwehr von extremistischen Bestrebungen,
aller Art, ne? Da gibt's verschiedene Kategorien, Rechtsextremismus, Linksextremismus, äh Islamismus, Ausländer, Extremismus, keine Ahnung, also so eine gibt's ein Kategorien und da schauen die und dann äh,
machen die Überwachung einerseits äh von öffentlich zugänglichen Quellen und dann aber eben auch mit klassischen, geheimdienstlichen Mitteln.
Und der den Unterschied zwischen Geheimdienst und Polizei müssen wahrscheinlich auch nochmal erklär.
Soll ich jetzt erklären.
Du kennst den, das weiß ich.
Ah, jetzt willst mich hier jetzt.
Ach so, nee, okay, dann mache ich's. Also der.
Du kannst, ich weiß, dass du, also der, der Unterschied ist, die Polizei macht Strafverfolgung und hat dafür beschränk.
Ordnung.
Und hat dafür beschränkte ähm
Möglichkeiten der ähm der der Überwachung und so weiter, wie wir gerade oder wie ich ja gerade schon sagte, Quellen TKÜ nur bei Verdacht so und so und bei falsch parken eben nicht,
Und ähm der Geheimdienst macht keine Strafverfolgung,
hat aber dafür auch im Prinzip keine nennenswerten Beschränkungen darin, äh welcher Anfangsverdacht oder sonst was existieren müsste.
Nicht richtig kontrolliert
Also, weiß ja keiner, was sie genau machen. Also es ist genau und die Polizei ist, ist, äh, ist zwar auch äh nicht transparent genug, aber ist doch halt transparenter und die Polizei gibt's natürlich auch nicht, sondern es gibt Länderpolizei und die Bundespolizei. Beim Verfassungsschutz auch, ne?
Polizei darf das, was sie äh erhebt gegen dich verwenden
Und darf das dann am Ende auch vor im im Gerichtsverfahren einbringen, wenn sie das Gemäß ihrer Regeln äh erhoben hat, einen Geheimdienst für den gelten im Prinzip solche Regeln nicht? Und der kann dich aber auch dafür dann äh letztendlich nicht anzeigen,
Ja, der muss dann irgendwie, der muss der Polizei einen Geheimtipp geben, wie sie,
wie heißt der Begriff Parallel Construction, ne? Also der Geheimdienst weiß es und dann muss das FBI aber noch eine eine legal äh eine legale Indizienkette finden, um um die Leute dann wirklich zu verhaften.
Und jetzt möchte der ach so genau der Inlandsgeheimdienst Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz macht das in Deutschland unter entsprechenden Regeln und der BND macht das im Ausland. Und ich glaube auch nur im Ausland.
Und eigentlich auch nur gegen Ausländer. Ja. Also dafür nicht Deutsche überwachen.
Jetzt mit diesem Gesetzesentwurf sollen sowohl Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz als auch BND der Eingriff informationstechnische Systeme erlaubt werden.
Nicht nur Computer und Smartphones, sondern auch was weiß ich, IT-Systeme im Internet der Dinge oder Autos, alle, also informationstechnische Systeme ähm grundsätzlich dürfen sie,
eingreifen und es wird auch nicht der nicht mehr der Unterschied gemacht, der bei der Polizei ja noch gemacht wird zwischen Onlinedurchsuchung und äh Quellen-TKÜ,
denn der ist beim Geheimdienst, also spielt keine Rolle, Verfassungsschutz darf also dann nicht nur Geräte.
Irgendwie abhören, sondern auch die die Platte durchsuchen, es geht noch weiter, nicht nur Geräte von direkten Gefährdern und Zielpersonen, sondern auch IT-Systeme, die Informationen von Gefährdern verarbeiten.
Ähm das gilt auch, wenn andere Personen als die Zielperson unvermeidlich mitbetroffen sind. Das ist dann so der Klassiker, okay, wir hacken Demail, weil irgendein Terrorkind äh hat.
Das ist echt äh relativ hart. Und äh gerade beim Verfassungsschutz, das ist ja der Inlandsgeheimdienst, das heißt, die würden.
Stehe gegen deutsche Infrastrukturen vorgehen und könnten Schleppnetz beifangen.
Deutschland haben und das wäre schon mal erlaubt. Im Prinzip der das war das große Thema immer in den äh in den unterschiedlichen Skandalen um den NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss.
Denn der BND hat das ja eh schon immer so gemacht, dass sie sagen ja äh wir wir dürfen im Ausland sowieso so ziemlich alles hacken, solange es Erkenntnisse von außen außen und sicherheitspolitischer Bedeutung verspricht. Das heißt, da waren die,
ähm Hürden ohnehin nicht besonders groß, Netzpolitik Ork, wo der,
der, wo dieser Gesetzesentwurf veröffentlicht wurde, zitiert auch, haben einen afghanischen Minister gehackt und äh dabei dann noch eine deutsche Journalistin als Beifang gehabt, das war aber völlig in Ordnung.
Gehobelt wird, fallen Späne, oder?
Also wo wo Nadeln gefunden werden, da werden Heuhaufen gesammelt oder so, ne? Ähm.
Jetzt soll der BND diese Staatstriane nicht nur für sich selbst einsetzen, sondern auch für andere, also die die deutschen Behörden sollen dem BND quasi für sich hacken lassen können,
ähm Amtshilfe als Ressourcen,
schonende Zusammenarbeit wird er also gesehen. Also wenn jetzt irgendwie so eine Polizeibehörde sagt, ach ja hier dann müssen wir mal hier hacken wegen,
Was weiß ich, Ermittlungsverfahren nach Paragraph hundertneunundzwanzig oder so, ne? Dann äh wird der direkte BND äh abgesetzt, der ja eigentlich nur im Ausland einsetzen. So durfte aber der kann das ja, ne? Also du siehst im Prinzip so genau dieses.
Diese Zitis.
Hackerbehörde quasi.
Hackerbehörde zitis, wo das, wo das ja schon irgendwie auch so ähm muss ich jetzt auch mal sagen, es ist natürlich klar, dass der Staat.
Wenn die schon einen Staatsrianer nicht hinkriegen, natürlich mit mit.
Sechzehn Startfrühjahren einen unterschiedlichen.
So, dass sie sich darüber Gedanken machen, sechzehn Landespolizeien, eine Bundespolizei, einen äh Verfassungsschutz, dass sie sich irgendwie überlegen, da müssen wir die Ressourcen bündeln, wenn wir schon, wenn sie schon vereinen,
Trojaner nicht wirklich reicht. Interessant ist aber, dass der BND ja seine Methoden nicht offenlegen muss. Der BND,
als Geheimdienst hat hier eine ganz andere Kontrolle als so eine Polizeibehörde und eine der zentralen Forderungen ist für Staatstrojaner im TKÜ-Bereich ist ja im Prinzip, dass man sagt, wenn ihr sowas schon macht, dann müsst ihr wenigstens
Kette vollständig offenlegen, alle Daten, die ihr erhoben habt, wie ihr das gemacht habt, um hier natürlich auch die verfassungsrechtlichen.
Den Schutz der Zielperson irgendwie sicherzustellen, dass sie hier kontrollieren kann, ob die Ermittlungsverfahren und Ermittlungsmethoden, die gegen sie eingesetzt wurden, sich im Verfassungsrechtlichen Rahmen befinden. Das ähm,
Ist natürlich nicht unbedingt so, wenn jetzt den BND äh für die für die Polizeidienststelle Buxtehude äh irgendwelche äh Drogenschmuggler hacken lässt.
Tja.
Wie das so ist bei solchen äh Gesetzen, es geht los mit ähm einer ein Protest der SPD.
Ja, man muss dazu sagen, Frau Barley wird uns ja als Justizministerin äh demnächst verlassen und Richtung Europa als Spitzenkandidatin gehen. Und ich habe ja so einen leisen Verdacht ähm,
Frau Barley, jetzt aber ganz stark dagegen ist und dann kommt irgendwie nach neuer Justizminister und dann,
macht die SPD das, was sie sonst auch noch tut
Also man weiß es nicht, aber es ist so ein bisschen klingt es so, ne? Frau Barley, hat das ja auch, sage ich schon wieder bei den Upload-Filtern, hat sie ja auch als wendig bewiesen,
und da versucht irgendwie die Sachen immer von sich fernzuhalten, ne? Die kann das ganz gut ähm mal sehen.
Die SPD geht auf die Barrikaden, schreibt die TAZ einen Burkhard Lischka, lässt sich zitieren in der TAZ mit der SPD ist das nicht zu machen,
Ja, da haben wir aber schon öfter gesehen, ne? Also äh mit der SPD ist das nicht zu machen. Wir können natürlich hoffen, dass das in irgendeiner Form hm.
Eingeschränkt wird, ähm! Aber wir.
Wie das so dann läuft. Spannend ist, dass diese Gesetzesentwürfe, die haben ja immer, diese sehr interessante äh diesen Einstieg, Problem und Ziel,
Lösung, Alternativen, Haushaltsausgaben ohne Erfüllungsaufwand, Erfüllungsaufwand und schön ist immer.
Unter Alternativen steht in der Regel keiner. Weil ich meine, wenn du eine Alternative hättest, warum würdest du dann ähm.
Das Gesetz machen.
Warum wir das ein Gesetz äh machen. Aber ähm und Erfüllungsaufwänder steht äh auf Erfüllungsaufwand steht immer nur, kann ein Aufwand entstehen. Ähm.
Näher beschränkt, äh äh benannt. Tja, also.
Geheimdienste in allen Runden, in allen Umgebungen und auch hier können wir natürlich wieder versuchen, dagegen vorzugehen. Ich denke aber dieses Geheimdienstthema ist eh so ein.
Spätestens mit dem NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss hatte das halt jetzt auch seine seine.
Da gab's die große Öffentlichkeit, da gab es die große Debatte und da hat man echt gesehen, wie dieses Thema so.
Tja, ich hab's ja auch gesagt bei den Upload-Filtern, das hing einem dann irgendwann zum Hals so raus, ne? Da und und das war bei dem bei dem bei den ganzen NSA-Skandalen.
Auch so. Ich meine, es war auch das erste Mal, dass so eine, also das war ja die groß angelegte Strategie von AdWords Norden zu sagen, wir halten diese Themen.
Durch oder von von Glengween World oder wie auch immer ähm
Wir halten dieses Thema, damit es nicht ein Stromfeuer ist, halten wir es durch immer neue Enthüllungen in der Öffentlichkeit
Bis dann irgendwann alle den Überblick verloren hatten bis auf vielleicht ein paar Leute in der Redaktion von Netzwerk Org, die in jeder schönen Sitzung des NSR-Untersuchungsausschusses saßen oder eben die wenigen Leute, die den NSR-Untersuchungsausschuss äh kritisch begleitet haben als Mitglieder. Ähm Martina Renner, die bei LMP zweihundertsechsundfünfzig zu Gast war,
Constantin von Nords, der ja immer noch nicht hier zu Gast war, müssen wir echt mal irgendwie langsam uns beschweren. Und ähm.
Ja, das hat Aufmerksamkeitsökonomie, ne? Das ist halt schwierig und das gibt halt immer so ein paar Leute, die die ganze Zeit dran bleiben und sich dieses Leid die ganze Zeit anschauen und es gibt,
ich weiß nicht genau, ich finde bei dem ganzen Sicherheitsthema muss man vielleicht mal einen anderen Hebel finden als immer an dem einzelnen äh,
Gesetz wieder zu sagen, oh nein, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, tut es nicht und dann passiert's trotzdem oder wird durch die SPD heldenhaft abgeschwächt auf Stadt, Kinder dürfen jetzt dann a,
statt generell dann ab sieben Jahren dann beobachtet werden. Also das ist ja dann später der Kompromiss, den sie rausgeschlagen haben. Ähm,
Äh ich ich weiß nicht, das ist halt, ist das schwierig.
Wir führen das halt leider seit seit so vielen Jahren immer nur als Abwehrkampf, ne. Wenn die die großen Erfolge, also korrigiere mich, wenn ich da jetzt gerade,
wieder zu pessimistisch werde, aber die die großen Erfolge sind dann sowas wie Vorratsdatenspeicherung.
Zehn Jahre lang dran gekämpft. Ja, Zinsus war ja, war ja noch nicht mal eine Überwachungssache, doch die wollten ja auch diese diese Sperrtafeln dann natürlich erfassen, wer da.
Ja, ich meine, das ist halt auf dem, also ich ich bei diesem ganzen Thema Grundrechte Überwachung und so,
kämpfen wir halt gegen gegen so ein so ein ein Narrativ, was immer sagt, dies wird alles,
gefährlicher und und die dieses dieses Böse, was überall ist und das stimmt halt einfach nicht. Diese Woche wird die Kriminalstatistik äh,
vorgestellt zum Beispiel sind die Einbrüche auf einem zwanzig Jahrestief, ja? Einbrüche, Wohnungseinbrüche,
Eins der Sachen, die die Menschen wirklich betrifft, ne? Und die wirklich nervig sind und wirklich Angst machen und so.
Nervig, ja?
Also nee das ist ja so ein so ein Thema, was wirklich irgendwie äh wo Leute Schiss vorhaben. Ja. Und das Ding ist, ist,
äh tatsächlich irgendwie runtergegangen, aber ich habe das Gefühl, dass diese dieses,
diese Erzählung von dieser giftgefährlichen Gesellschaft, die Leute haben halt einen komplett falsches Bild davon. Es gab mal so eine Umfrage, da kam raus, dass quasi ähm ich glaube, ich zwei Drittel bis dreiviertel je nach Altersgruppe, ne, je älter, desto Angst,
Ähm äh das komplett falsch sehen. Die denken alle, die Kriminalität geht hoch und das stimmt einfach nicht. Und da ich da muss man ran an diese Angstgesellschaft
dazu führt, dass Leute ihre Kinder, die die Erstklässler nicht mehr zur Schule laufen, irgendwie früher waren's achtzig Prozent aller Erstklässler, heute sind's noch zwölf,
oder siebzehn, also er ist auf jeden Fall nach zwanzig Jahre später geht laufen die alle nicht mehr hin, weil die Eltern Angst haben, oh, die Kinder könnten dann könnte was passieren. Es ist aber nicht,
gefährlicher geworden. Also und da da muss man irgendwie ran, muss überlegen, wie.
Eine, was deinem Kind passieren kann ist, dass es von so einem scheiß LKW ohne äh ohne toten Winkelerkennungsmechanismus an der Ampel umgenietet wird. Das.
Die Erbe der Verkehrsunfälle sind ja auch haben wir auch nicht glaube ich Zuge, also da ist dieses dieses subjektive.
Wohnungseinbrüche, dass die Wohnungseinbrüche tatsächlich sogar zurückgehen, das hab sogar selbst ich nicht gedacht.
Es geht auch die Gewaltkriminalität, äh Mord und Totschlag, es geht eigentlich alles zurück,
Vielleicht gibt's einzelne Sachen, die hochgehen, weil einfach Digitalisierung und dann gibt's halt mehr Computer, Kriminalität oder Betrug im Internet oder so, aber äh das hat hängt dann mit Technik zusammen
das das ist halt ich glaube die Gesellschaft ist gepolt und das liegt natürlich an so Nachrichtenfaktoren wie Negativität geht immer so ne? Jedes Medium muss immer geil ist wenn's wenn's wenn's wenn's kracht und spengelt, dann dann,
kann ich darüber berichten, Politiker können ganz leicht drauf, ja wir tun, was man ja verschärfen, verschärfen, verschärfen und das ist so ein Kreislauf und an den müssen wir,
Generelle, wenn, wenn wir immer das Einzelgesetz klar ist wichtig dagegen was zu tun, aber,
Aber ich glaube dieser, wenn wir den Kreislauf nicht durchbrechen, diesen Angst und subjektive Unsicherheitsgefühl, mit dem wir auch heute argumentiert wird. Oh, das ist ein gefährlicher Ort, sondern an diesem Ort fühlen sich Leute unsicher. Deswegen brauchen wir da mehr Überwachung. Es
totaler Quatsch. Also mein, dann.
Könnte, also eigentlich so der der Job des Innenministers könnte so einfach sein, ja, sich hinzustellen, ja, geht alles runter, super geiler Job hier, alles cool, aber dann hast du halt so eine.
Naja, die äh die Argumentation vor dem ist, es geht alles runter, weil wir ja so har,
greifen und wenn's irgendwas ist, dann ist es oh, wir müssen härter durchgreifen, damit's runter geht. Also du kommst aus dieser Kette nicht raus und ich glaube, das wäre mal eine, also wir haben mal Ansätze zu finden, wie man diese Angstgesellschaft
in der dann eben nicht die man sieht es ja an an also,
Mit älteren Menschen spricht ist es noch viel viel härter, die haben unglaubliche Angst, nur wenn man da fragt, ja ist denen denn mal was passiert.
Also wir leben in einem der sichersten Länder der Welt, ja? Also es ist es ist total absurd, äh ständig,
diese Überwachungskriminalitätsbekämpfungsschraube weiter anzuziehen. Also.
Stimmt ein. Also sie hat Angst ist wirklich oder du hast du hast Recht, weil das Angst ist deshalb ein schlechter,
Ein schlechter Ratgeber übrigens auch etwas, was man in der in der Psychologie ja sogar äh nicht ohne Grundtherapiert, ja?
Wenn du, wenn du zu viel Angst hast, das das wird therapiert, da wird dir geholfen, das wieder loszuwerden, weil das.
Frage, wie die Therapie für eine Gesellschaft aussieht, die in Angst ist. Und wo kommt die her, ne? Kommt die, eigentlich kommt die jetzt wegen der Kriminalität oder kommt die, weil die Leute unsicher sind, dass sie ihren Job verlieren können. Also, man weiß es ja nicht so genau.
Würdest du sagen, okay, setz dich Risikosituationen aus und und stelle fest.
Alle oder was?
Einmal alle am Cott.
Platz muss man sagen, Cottbuser Tor in Kreuzberg, also.
Bisherigen Gefahr.
Naja, es es ist ein harter Ort, ne? Also das ist jetzt nicht so, dass denke, oh Kai, das setze ich mich jetzt länger hin und ist voll gemütlich und so. Aber ja, noch nie, was passiert dort? Also ist Erbe.
Was soll dir denn auch da passieren? Da steht an jeder Ecke ein Polizist. Ich meine der eine Ort, wo dir nix passiert, ist am am Cottbuser Tor.
Weiß ich nicht. Also es klappt da sind die Statistiken anders aus, aber äh ja aber na ich ich finde es ich,
das ist so eins der Grundprobleme und dafür haben wir keine politische Antwort und ich sehe die nirgendswo und vielleicht ist es auch sehr schwer da eine zu.
Aber dieses Denkmuster tatsächlich zu sagen, okay, Kriminalität ist zurückgegangen. Äh gut, wir haben unser Ziel erreicht. Ähm.
Das passiert eben nicht, sondern sagt, ah, ist zurückgegangen, okay, super, wir machen, das ist also richtig, Überwachung hilft. Ja, wir wir machen jetzt weiter mit mit dem,
wenn's nicht zurückgeht, dann war das untauglich, dann müssen wir mehr machen, ne? Also es gibt quasi unabhängig von dem, was passiert, muss auf jeden Fall mehr gemacht werden. Das ist natürlich ein kaputtes Denkmuster, das ist auch etwas, was der Chaos-Computerclub immer wieder fordert. Ich habe das,
auch schon, also ne, wenn wir die Gelegenheit dazu haben, fordern wir das Evidenz basierte,
Sicherheitspolitik, ja? Also wenn wenn schon der die Emotionen der Bürger es nicht erfassen, dann müssen wir eben solche Sachen,
proben, ja? Das war auch, habe ich in der gerade zitierten Staatsrehörung natürlich auch gesagt, okay, dann macht das Gesetz von mir aus, aber.
Erfasst bitte ähm nach einem einem Jahr oder nach zwei oder nach fünf.
Wie viel euch dieses Ermittlungsinstrument tatsächlich gebracht hat, denn um nochmal ganz kurz in so eine wissenschaftliche Betrachtung zu gehen, da saß ja dann auch der ähm Herr vom BKA,
Vizechef Club Hänsel heißt er. Ähm und sagte so.
So und so viele äh kriminelle mussten wir laufen lassen, weil wir nicht die Smartphones hacken konnten. Und du sagst so.
Sorry, das ist ein nicht zulässiger Schluss, den du hier gerade als informierter Mensch,
mach's, weil es hätte, es kann genauso gut sein, dass diese Leute eben, wenn du deren Handys abgeholt abgehört hättest, sich als unschuldig erwiesen hätten,
und du einfach die falschen Personen,
will abgeabhören wolltest, ja? Und dann sagt er irgendwie, äh, ja, nee, ich wusste ja, dass die schuldig sind, dann fragst du dich so, wenn du wusstest, dass sie schuldig sind. Warum hast du denn nicht, warum hast du sie da nicht eingeknackt,
Ja, warum hast du sie dann nicht mit mit den Existenten Ermittlungsmethoden ähm fangen können? Und das ist natürlich ähm.
Also das ist halt ein nicht zulässiger Schluss und ist eine Gesellschaft ist immer schlecht beraten, wenn sie nicht evidenzbasiert, agiert,
und und gerade den Abbau von Grundrechten und die Einschränkung von von Grundrechten irgendwie sehr, sehr, sehr kritisch und evidenzbasiert.
Ey und Evides passiert, ich meine, kann man ja irgendwie sich anschauen. Wenn wir nochmal zu den Wohnungsanbrüchen gehen, ne? Da ist jetzt so,
staatliche Förderung von besseren Schlössern
Quasi, das ist glaube ich auch passiert. Äh aber wenn ich halt irgendwie einen Doppelschloss und eine ordentliche Türe drin mache und das irgendwie den Aufwand, das zu knacken irgendwie von drei Minuten auf fünfzehn Minuten erhöhe, dann habe ich Evidenz basiert, dann bringt es was
Habe ich niemanden geschadet, ist vielleicht ein bisschen.
Du hast ja im Nachbarn geschadet, weil dann brechen die da einen, aber.
Okay, wenn du hast einen Luftballoneffekt, du hast dich verdrängt und so, aber generell ist das natürlich, das ist eine, da geht kein Grundrecht kaputt, das sieht ein bisschen paranoiamäßig aus, wenn da vier Schlösser sind und so eine dicke Stahltür, aber äh nein, aber es ist, es gibt.
Wenn du Angst hast, dass da jemand was wegnimmt, dann kannst du ja ohne Stahltür dahin bauen.
Genau und es wird halt nicht versucht äh ganz häufig nicht versucht zu sagen, okay, was was hilft denn jetzt wirklich? Und man hat halt einfach diese.
Apparate, ne? Also jedes Sicherheitsapparat hat halt ein Eigeninteresse stärker zu werden, alte gute Systemtheorie und das passiert dann die ganze Zeit.
Ich stelle das übrigens auch fest, mit mit ähm mit IT-Sicherheit, ne? Also so diffuse Angst ist im Prinzip das Schlimmste, was du Leuten antun kannst. Weil die nicht wissen,
wie sie sich schützen sollen. Und ähm,
irgendwie so, ne? Wenn ich irgendwie einen Vortrag halte über IT-Sicherheit oder so, komm, jedes Mal irgendwelche Leute an, mit irgendein aufs Kurvengerät in der Hand oder irgendeine App oder irgendwas. Ich habe jetzt hier so und so ist das sicher. Und kannst den hundert Mal erklären, so wovor,
weiß ich nicht, Hacker ähm vor vor Social Bots.
Ja, aber die Tage ist auch äh so in den ganzen Themen ist es fehlt, irgend sich Empirie. Verdammt nochmal. Also.
Wäre echt mal schön.
Ja, also das führt natürlich ein bisschen,
von der Online-Durchsuchung, aber es geht es fehlt wirklich diese die Beweisführung, dass man vielleicht auch in Gesetzen beweisen muss. Und dann haben wir das eingeführt und drei Jahre später wird evaluiert und dann oh, hat was gebracht.
Ja, wir brauchen einfach auch mal Mut zur Schutzlücke. So, ähm wir kommen.
Glaube ich zur nächsten Schutzlücke und äh neben Kindern sehr eine sehr wichtige Schutzlücke, die in Deutschland noch immer wieder für ungemaß sorgt, ist die Kunst.
Ja, also ganz ja äh.
Diese Geschichte entwickelt sich gerade eigentlich in in Zeiten äh wo wir das hier aufzeichnen.
Und zwar wird gegen das Zentrum für politische Schönheit, also die wahrscheinlich bekannteste und umstrittenste Aktionskünstlergruppe,
Deutschland wird in Thüringen,
wegen Bildung einer kriminellen Vereinigung ermittelt. Ich denke, er ist sofort immer an so Rockerbanden und so. Aber so organisierte Kriminalität und so. Genau und das ist Paragraph hundertneunundneunzig und,
diese Ermittlungen äh eröffnen dem Staatsapparat, also das ist eine der schärfsten.
Die man so haben kann, wenn man gegen jemand vorgehen will, eröffnen also das komplett Arsenal der Überwachung, also.
Kann ich irgendwie von V-Männern einsetzen, die Post kontrollieren, Telefonüberwachung, langfristige Observationen machen, ich kann verdeckte Ermittler einsetzen, Rastafahndungen, großer Lauschangriff, also da geht alles und äh,
In diesem Fall geht's gegen,
eben eine Künstlergruppe, die ja immer wieder mit bundesweiten bundesweiten Debatten und eben mit mit kontroversen Aktionen auf sich aufmerksam macht, äh,
ich finde harter Tubak, was da,
da passiert das Verfahren läuft seit sechzehn Monaten und es wurde interessanterweise also im November zweitausendsiebzehn hat das Zentrum,
politische Schönheit dem Rechtsradikalen AfD-Politiker Björn Höcke, ein Stehlen fällt ein Holocaust Mahnmal vor die Tür gesetzt.
In diesem Zusammenhang ist dieses Verfahren eben im äh in Thüringen, bei der Staatsanwaltschaft Gera eröffnet worden. Ähm.
Wir erinnern uns ja, was äh Björn Höcke damals dazu sagt.
Genau, ich mein das,
ist äh dass es ein auffälliges Detail in diesem Fall, also nur ein paar Tage nachdem eben Björn Höcke bei dieser rechtsradikalen Kompakt äh Konferenz diesen dass die Künstler eine kriminelle Vereinigung nennt.
Wird quasi das Ermittlungsverfahren äh in in Gera äh eröffnet.
Und die AfD Thüringen hat das dann später auch noch getwittert, oh eine kriminelle Vereinigung so. Man weiß jetzt noch nicht, wie das zustande gekommen ist. Also wer hat da wie angezeigt, wer hat da, warum das Verfahren aufgenommen,
wie wurde da überwacht da hat die Staatsanwaltschaft Gera auf meine Anfrage,
gesagt, ja also aus ermittlungstaktischen Gründen können wir dann nichts zu sagen. Das die Sache ist auf jeden Fall sehr heiß und es ist irgendwie in der in der jüngeren Geschichte äh kein Fall eigentlich bekannt, wo gegen Künstler,
Die alle unbescholten und niemals strafrechtlich verurteilt wurden, das muss ja außer auch noch so ein Ding, also es ist nicht so, dass hat's hiermit irgendwie Schwerkriminellen zu tun hat, die sich.
Die haben nicht eine einzige äh die haben oder haben die wirklich keine einzige Straf.
Straf. Sie wurden strafrechtlich soweit mir das vorliegt äh nicht äh verurteilt. Wahrscheinlich haben sie irgendwie zivilrechtlich schon mal was verloren, aber ja, also das ist ja nicht.
Glaube ich, wie durften sich der Frau Höcke nicht mehr nähern oder sowas, ne? Da gab's doch irgendw.
Genau, aber es ist nicht also strafrechtlich ist liegt da nichts vor und das ist schon, also in meinen Augen ist das ein Angriff auf die, auf die Freiheit der Kunst, wenn man,
eben hier gegen unbequeme Künstler, die eben auch immer wieder in den Wunden bohren und die die äh,
die sind auch die Regierung damit stressen und äh und die Ministerien stressen und einfach mit mit so kontroverser Kunst hantieren, dass es eben immer den großen medialen Spektakel äh dass es das gibt,
dass das natürlich irgendwie unbequem ist, aber wer will und wer will denn bequeme Kunst denken, dass.
Fahrstuhlfahrer, Fahrstuhlfahrer wollen bequeme Kunst so ein bisschen Fahrstuhl,
dass es äh bequemes Gedudel. Ich finde tatsächlich sowieso Kunst ist nur dann,
überhaupt zu zu als solche zu würdigen
Wenn sie in irgendeiner Form ein ähm Diskussionsprozess, eine emotionale Auseinandersetzung oder irgendeine Form von Denkprozess ähm anlenkt.
Der dann irgendwie anders ist,
Ja, wo die die etwas auslöst, muss jetzt nicht alles immer äh politische äh politische Schönheitsaktionen sein, ne? Aber ein wirkliches Kunstwerk löst etwas aus.
In deinem Kopf, in deinem, es muss ein Gefühl auslösen, Emotionen, das macht und und das ist halt Kunst, was die machen. Und weil sie gerade spielen,
mit den Grenzen auf der Kunst und da ist das erlaubt, kann man das und also aber das ist ich find's ein ungeheuerlichen Vorgang, dass äh in Deutschland gegen Künstler,
solchen Mitteln irgendwie vorgegangen wird, vollkommen irrsinnig äh und ja, also.
Aber ist das noch Kunst? Ich meine, das ist ja eine Frage, so ist das Zentrum für politische Schönheit Kunst. Ich sage ja.
Ich würde auch sagen, ja.
Gut, dann haben wir auch mal das, um hier zu diskutieren, vielleicht nur noch zu begründen. Also genau dieses dieses Auslösen, das hm,
die diese Aktion zeigen ja im Prinzip die führen ja.
Eigentlich immer die gesamte mediale Landschaft vor, weil du kannst eigentlich nicht, also wenn du dich der der Position der Aktion, des Zentrums völlig kritiklos anschließt und sagt, das finde ich alles in Ordnung.
Nee, das kannst du ja nicht.
Kannst du nicht machen
Weil da damit, damit gehst du denn auf den Leim, ja, damit führen sie dich vor. Wenn du aber sagst, diese Aktion finde ich absolut nicht, die können die nicht machen, die können ja nicht einfach ein Haus mieten und und ihren Garten nach Lust und Laune umgestalten, das geht halt auch nicht, ne?
Ne, sie haben ja gesagt, ja, wenn dem Höcke das hier nicht gefällt, unser kleines. Äh unsere kleine äh Stehlen-Installation in unserem Garten,
dann kann er ja ein Kniefall davor machen, dann machen wir es wieder weg. Ja? Ähm.
Ja, ich meine, das, die, die Aktionen haben immer viele Ebenen, sie spielen neben, das ist ja Theater im,
öffentlichen Raum und jeder, der da irgendwie Teil wird, der eine macht eine Anzeige gegen die, der Nächste schreibt was drüber und alle werden irgendwie zu Schauspielern in diesem,
in diesem großen Theater Theaterstück genau.
Alle die sich da alle müssen sich im Prinzip.
Positionieren, alle müssen irgendwie, also jetzt ist das und also das ist, es ist auf jeden Fall Kunst, es ist natürlich auch politische Kunst, aber warum auch nicht. Also.
Also ich erwarte von Kunst, dass sie politisch ist, aber für von mir aus gibt's auch unpolitische Kunst, aber äh sehe ich irgendwie selten.
Ja also ja und jetzt also das große Problem an sowas ist natürlich, also muss dazu sagen, dass äh,
Philipp Bruch, der künstlerische Leiter der Gruppe wurde ja letztens schon von einem Kongress der Bundeszentrale für politische Bildung ausgeladen auf Weisung des Innenministeriums mit Verweis,
auf ein laufendes Verfahren und jetzt wissen wir auch wahrscheinlich welches Verfahren das ist, nämlich ein Verfahren nach Paragraph hundertneunundzwanzig, also nicht hundertneunundzwanzig A, das ist Terrorismus, sondern eben Bildung einer kriminellen Vereinigung und.
Kann das mal ganz kurz vorlesen, wenn du möchtest. Ähm, Paragraph neunundzwanzig,
hundertneunundzwanzig STGB mit Freiheitsstrafe bis zu fünf Jahren oder mit Geldbestrafung wird bestraft. Wer eine Vereinigung gründet,
oder sich an einer Vereinigung als Mitglied beteiligt, deren Zweck oder Tätigkeit auf die Begehung von Straftaten gerichtet ist,
die im Höchstmaß mit Freiheitsstrafe von mindestens zwei Jahren bedroht sind. Die Freiheitsstrafe mit Freiheitsstrafe bis zu drei Jahren oder mit Geldstrafe wird bestraft, wer eine solche Vereinigung unterstützt.
Oder für sie um Mitglieder und Unterstützer wirbt. Huiui, das ist ich glaube, ähm unterstützt habe ich die auch schon.
Ja, das haben wahrscheinlich sehr viele Leute unterstützt, denn äh die äh leben auch von Spenden und sie leben natürlich auch von,
von Geldern, die über Theater kommen und da kommen wir zu dem nächsten Punkt, der diese Sache halt irgendwie problematisch macht. Das ist eine Stigmatisierung und eine Vorverurteilung ja nun mal, ja, dass er eine kriminelle Vereinigung, damit ermittelt, wenn er jetzt dann irgendwo,
Theatermacher bist oder irgendwie eine eine der Zuwendungsgelder vom Staat bekommt und denkt sich, aber damit will ich nichts zu tun haben,
Man stigmatisiert diese Leute, die und und macht sie quasi unmöglich, bei zumindest bei bestimmten Kreisen.
Und und schadet ihnen, das wird irgendwie Auftrittsmöglichkeiten eventuell beschränken, das wird irgendwie Gelder und Unterstützung für diese Kunst äh beschränken und,
dann kommt man eben genau in das Fahrwasser der AfD, die das immer schon gefordert hat, die wollten die, dass es, also,
Ich, also wenn man hart auf hart formulieren will, macht sich eben die Staatsanwaltschaft Gera zum Handlanger eigentlich für eine AfD-Politik gegen Kunst. Und äh,
Ich glaube, das Beste, was ihr machen könnt, ist die äh zu unterstützen in verschiedenen,
und dann gleich in den Fokus der Ermittlungen zu geraten. Nein. Unterstützend, also Solidarität mit denen ihr, ihr seid da auch betroffen, also ich fühle mich da äh ich sehe das als ein Angriff auf die Freiheit der Kunst insgesamt und wir können nicht irgendwie,
irgendwie sagen uh der böse Erdogan und der böse Putin, wenn wir selber gegen irgendwie die bekannteste Aktionskünstlergruppe äh mit ähnlich schweren ähm,
Mitteln vorgehen. Also das ist schon.
Völliger völliger Irrsinn, ja. Jetzt ist die Frage, also nur mal um einen blöden Vergleich zu ziehen. Es gibt ja eine äh politische Gruppierung, die,
versucht dem dem Zentrum für politische Schönheit nachzueifern, dabei natürlich eigentlich regelmäßig sehr, sehr peinlich und kläglich scheitert,
ähm wie würdest du da, wie würdest du das sehen? Wenn jetzt gegen die Identitäre Bewegung vorgegangen wird.
Ja, die identitäre Bewegung ist halt glaube ich nicht Kunst, weil sie.
Die benutzt zwar Mittel der Kommunikationsgeräte, Mittel aus äh Company, Greenpeace, Campaigning, zivil ungehorsam, hat das irgendwie schön kopiert, hat sich da irgendwie angelehnt, aber letztlich äh,
dass man einen äh glaube ich einen großen Unterschied in in dem in dem Weltbild.
Im Gegensatz zu dem Humanismus, den das Zentrum propagieren äh äh
propagieren, die irgendwie Rassismus verbrämten Rassismus, ne? Also Rassismus, der sich unter Ethno, Pluralismus irgendwie versteckt, aber letztlich die Reinhaltung der Rasse und der große Austausch und unser Blut zersteckt da alles drin, das haben die nur,
Die wollen halt die ganze Zeit dreiunddreißig bis fünfundvierzig ausblenden mit dem Holzhammer, aber schaffen sie ja zunehmend nicht mehr und ähm.
Die Identitären, ich glaube, dass sie quasi sie waren immer Nazis und jetzt äh können sie dieses bürgerliche kaum noch äh äh halten,
der Attentäter von Christchurch äh beruft sich quasi auf ihre Ideologie eins zu eins.
Geld gespendet.
Hat ihnen Geld gespendet und was auf jeden Fall da passiert ist, dass diese diese bürgerliche Wesen demokratische, patriotische Bürger, die hier mit,
Aktionismus auftreten. Diese dieser Mantel wird nicht mehr gehalten. Ich würde die nicht vergleichen, denn ich fand die Aktion von,
von der Identitären, die waren nur spektakulär, weil von rechts gab's das noch nicht äh und klar aus Brandenburger Tor zu gehen, das muss man erstmal machen, aber letztlich ist es
hat Greenpeace das halt auch schon seit dreißig Jahren immer wieder irgendwie gemacht und das war nur die konnten sich halt gut verkaufen als Bewegung mit ihren Poster Boys und so äh
ich ich sehe da, kann man nicht vergleichen, ist nicht Kunst.
Kunst ist es nicht. Ähm Frage ist, ist es kriminelle Vereinigung.
Sich auch nicht bewerten, ob's eine kriminelle Vereinigung ist.
Mit ihrem Boot, mit dem sie da aufs Mittelmeer fahren wollten, um andere Menschen äh daran zu hindern, Schiffbrüchige zu retten,
in meinem Strafgesetzbuch wäre das zumindest unterlassene Hilfeleistung, wenn nicht gar
Beihilfe zum Menschen ertrinken lassen
da könnte man fast sogar sein, dass das eine kriminelle Vereinigung ist, aber dann hätte man natürlich auch wieder sich überlegen müssen, dass die ganzen Boote von Maren Nostrum oder ähm äh der libyschen Küstenwache,
kriminelle Vereinigung sind. Übrigens eine Argumentation, in der sich das Zentrum für politische Schönheit wahrscheinlich genau in der Form auch anschließen würde.
Ja, also ich sehe, ich sehe, ich das äh ich glaube, dass also dass die nicht vergleichbar sind, weil das Zentrum immer dann doch äh da ist die Kunst bei aller Politik die Kunst dann doch äh und es ist auch viel vielschichtiger und ist nicht so eine plumpe.
Mir geht's, mir geht's, mir geht's so ein bisschen um die Frage, ist.
Dafür Ausschluss äh ausschlaggebend, ob das Zentrum Kunst ist oder nicht. Wenn man jetzt sagt, die Aktion des Zentrums für politische Schönheit äh sind jetzt keine Kunst.
Also er ist eine Politgruppe quasi, würde man.
Eine Politgruppe, das sind jetzt das sind das ist jetzt so was weiß ich der große Weiserat der Künstler ähm hat entschieden, dass jetzt keine Kunst, ja? Ähm, fra.
Selbst dann wäre ja keine kriminelle.
Hundert Kunstprofessoren gefragt. Wer das dann, wäre das dann eine kriminelle Vereinigung? Und ich glaube, das ist nämlich unerheblich dafür.
Es ist unerheblich, man muss auch dazu sagen, kriminelle Vereinigung, also diese hundertneunundzwanziger Paragraph ist äh ein Paragraph bei dem im unteren einstelligen Bereich es zu Anklagen kommt.
Und am Ende zwischen ein und drei Prozent äh verurteilt werden. Also es ist, ist, ist ein Paragraph, der ist zum Ausforschen von Strukturen äh da, der wurde früh in den, in den,
als es noch nicht den hundertneunundzwanzig A, den Terrorismusparagraphen gab, wurde die genutzt, um eben um eben vor allem gegen KBD äh Strukturen äh,
im Nachkriegsdeutschland, in den beginnenden Jahren vorzugehen und diese Strukturen auszuforschen und erst auch heute noch,
politisches Instrument zur Ausforschung, der war lange Zeit gar nicht geeignet, um eben organisierte Kriminalität äh eigentlich dagegen vorzugehen, sondern ist ein eindeutig politischer Paragraph.
Ich würde hier noch ganz kurz äh also der Absatz zwei erklärt, was eine Vereinigung ist, ein auf Dauer angelegter
von einer Festlegung von Rollen der Mitglieder, der kennt Kontinuität der Mitgliedschaft und der Ausprägung der Struktur unabhängiger organisierter Zusammenschluss von mehr als zwei Personen zur Verfolgung eines Übergeordneten gemeinsamen Interesses, ja?
Zentrum für politische Schönheit ist eine Vereinigung. Ähm und dann finde ich sehr schön Satz drei. Absatz eins ist nicht anzuwenden,
erstens, wenn die Vereinigung eine politische Partei ist, die das Bundesverfassungsgericht nicht für verfassungswidrig erklärt hat. Zweitens, wenn die Begehung von Straftaten nur ein Zweck,
oder eine Tätigkeit von untergeordneter Bedeutung ist. Und das spätestens da hätte man als Staatsanwaltschaf.
Der Zweck dieser Kunst,
aufzurütteln in die Wunde rein, irgendwie Diskurs zu machen, Räume zu öffnen für für Debatte der Gesellschaft, einen Spiegel, vor allem, was auch immer, es geht ja nicht darum, wenn,
irgendwie ein Plakat illegal aufgestellt wird gegen Höcke, geht's ja nicht darum, ja wir wollen natürlich Straftaten, weil wir uns da bereichern wollen oder es ist nicht der der also mit meinem Laien juristischen Verständnis, würde sagen, äh, passt das alles nicht,
Und also das ist in meinen Augen ein Skandal, dass sowas äh möglich ist gegen Künstler.
Also ich denke, dieser ähm ähm Absatz drei Satz äh oder zweiter Punkt hätte auf jeden Fall diesen Aspekt schon schon beendet. Hätte man gar nicht weiterlesen müssen, hätte man sofort sagen können, so Anfangsverdacht ist schon mal grundsätzlich hier nicht gegeben.
Und warum macht man das nicht? Du hast es gerade schon gesagt. Ähm man macht das nicht, um eben diesen, weil dieser Verdacht eben die ganzen Ermittlungsmethoden ermöglicht,
weil man eben genauso wie übrigens das äh Ermittlungsverfahren gegen Netzpolitik, Org, wegen Landesfahrrads oder spezifisch war das gegen Netzwerk Orko, spezifisch gegen Markus Becke da unten andere Meister. Ich weiß gar nicht genau.
Das war gegen die beiden.
Ja ähm spezifisch äh der Verdacht natürlich im Raume stand, dass das gemacht wurde, um die Abhörmethoden zu haben,
weil man eben aufgrund dieses Anfangsverdachtes dann die die das Instrumentarium Online-Durchsuchung, Überwachung, TKÜ, äh, Observation, V-Leute und so weiter äh zur Verfügung hat, um dann,
natürlich in dem Rahmen ähm unter Umständen äh herauszufinden, wer die journalistischen Quellen,
der beiden waren, ja? Und ähm darf man natürlich auch nicht vergessen, wenn man sich anschaut, Finetzpolitik auch seitdem weitergemacht hat, wäre natürlich im Rahmen der der Tätigkeit durchaus auch von Interesse gewesen, wer zukünftig.
Und äh genau deswegen strengt man eben solche Ermittlungsverfahren an. Das ist ein Skandal und da muss jetzt sehr laut gegengegangen werden und ich würde mich sogar.
Vorsichtig dazu herablassen in einer Parallelrealität wo ähm.
Ah nee, würde ich wahrscheinlich nicht. Wenn die, wenn die wegen hundertneunundzwanzig gegen äh die identitäre Bewegung vorgehen würden, würde ich sagen, ja, ein Anfangsverdacht ist gegeben,
Also muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen. Nur nicht mal eine ästhetische, ich würde es begründen mit erstens ganz klar Volksverhetzung, ist eine Straftat. Diese Vereinigung hat den Zweck der Volksverhetzung zweitens ähm,
diese Ideen äh oder diese Versuche, sie waren ja am Ende zu doof, ein Schiff zu steuern und ihre Crew ist ja dann auch.
Nee, als Flüchtlinge, als Flüchtlinge und Geflüchtete äh.
Ne, aber sie haben auf jeden Fall ähm Aktionen gehabt, wo,
tatsächlich Straftaten. Das erklärte Ziel waren, ne? Menschen ertrinken lassen, ähm Volksverhetzung und Sonstiges. Ähm wenn da der Anfangsverdacht äh der Bildung einer kriminellen Vereinigung stünde, würde ich sagen, das finde ich ähm.
Argumentierbar,
ja? Ähm und äh ich finde das übrigens auch argumentierbar, dass die jetzt gerade Hausdurchsuchungen hatten wegen der Nähe zu dem äh Christchurch-Attentäter. Und ich finde es auch verargumentierbar, dass dieser,
Vollhong Martin Sellner nicht auf Anhieb, dass das Standardtouristenvisum in die USA bekommt musste ihm natürlich dann noch, dann hat er sich ja irgendwie groß darüber aufgeregt, dass die USA ihre Grenze nicht ganz so offen halten,
wie er sich das als als Area gerne wünscht.
Ähm einmal alle laut gelacht, ja? Alle laut gelacht, der wird schon in die USA einreisen können im Nachhinein stellt sich raus, wer mit einer US-Amerikanerin verlobt ist, kommt eh nicht mehr über das Standardtouristenvisum rein, weißt du wieso,
weil die Amis Angst haben, dass die die Familie nachholt,
wie der Sellner natürlich auch, ne? Für jeden Araber, den wir hier reinlassen, weiß ja nicht, wie viele Kinder der hier noch gebiert und das sind dann alles Deutsche und die zersetzen dann die Rasse ähnlich ähm sehen das die Amerikaner auch.
Insofern lassen wir das mal äh amüsiert außen vor. Also das ist ein Skandal, dass in dieser Form gegen eine Gruppe,
vorgegangen wird, die nach unserer Kenntnis keine strafrechtliche Verurteilung.
Ja, es ist ein Skandal, es ist ein, es, es ist quasi der Landesverrat bei Kunst quasi, ne? Das ist eine ähnliche Tragweite und es ist unmöglich und
Ich fühle mich schlecht, wenn in diesem Land irgendwie gegen Aktionskünstler mit sowas vorgegangen wird.
Interessanterweise, ich hätte äh also mir fällt auch nicht ein, dass die jemals irgendwie strafrechtlich belangt worden wären. Natürlich werden die eine Reihe an Ermittlungsverfahren im strafrechtlichen Rahmen.
Ja, da gab's nicht einen zick Anzeigen, die aber auch äh eingestellt wurden. Also.
Dafür haben wir den eben, dafür haben wir diese gesetzlichen Grenzen und wir haben eben unsere Gesetze auch für Freisprüche.
Genau, also äh keine schöne Sache ähm mal gucken, wie es weitergeht. Ich gehe davon aus, dass das Verfahren eingestellt wird, wenn der Protest und Aufschrei laut genug ist.
Aber das darf das finde ich auch irgendwie glaube ich damals schon bei bei den Landesvorratsermittlungen, ich meine
wir können nicht darauf äh wir können sich darauf verlassen, dass der Rechtsstaat irgendwie nur Rechtsstaat ist, wenn wenn man protestiert. Es gibt genug Menschen, die nicht den Zugang haben zu dieser Öffentlichkeit,
die Ungerechtigkeiten und sonstigen ausgesetzt sind und ich kann nicht aufhören zu fordern, dass wir,
verantwortungsbewusste oder verantwortliche Tätigkeiten von verantwortungsbewussten Menschen ausführen lassen. Und ähm das äh gilt insbesondere für äh Strafverfolgung.
Ja, also.
Hast du, hast du Statements vom ZPS eingeholt.
Hab ich gemacht aber noch sind die.
Na, wir veröffentlichen eh erst nach nachdem. Wir veröffentlichen ja eh erst nachdem äh die die Sperrfrist.
Na ja, Philipp Bruch sagt zum Beispiel der Staat radikalisiert sich zunehmend selbst und wenn Radikal diese radikale Kunst kriminalisiert wird, wird der Staat eben kriminell. Äh was und Stefan Pelzer, der äh,
Eskalationsbeauftragte,
äh des des Zentrums äh sagt, äh dass es ein Skandal sondergleichen. Es bräuchte jetzt ähm massiven zivilgesellschaftlichen Druck auf sämtliche Verantwortlichen in Thüringen.
Ähm und zwar weil dort die Justiz wohl äh auf die Verantwortlichen Thüringen, die seit äh die auf dem rechten Auge,
blind sein und nun nicht einmal davor zurückschrecken als Schoßhündchen der AfD-Nazis auf Missliebige Künstler loszugehen. Ähm,
Ja, das Zentrum ruft zu Spenden auf,
ähm und ja, braucht Unterstützung. Also es geht, glaube ich, hier auch um eine Verteidigung der Freiheit der Kunst in diesem Land und das ist nicht, das ist nicht weniger. Das ist ein,
Das ist wirklich krass.
Die brauchen, also sie werden natürlich auch die Spenden brauchen, um sich dagegen zu wehren, um da irgendwie Aufklärungen zu verlangen, um diesem, diesem Prozess nachzugehen. Und ich bin ja mal gespannt auf die
Kommentare in der Sendung. Die Aktionen des ZPS waren ja immer auch ähm in der Hörerschaft,
kontrovers äh berücksichtige aber bitte. Hier geht's eben um einen konkreten Vorwurf Bildung einer kriminellen Vereinigung. Und ähm das ist eben nicht die Frage, war die Aktion in Ordnung oder nicht?
Da bin ich sehr gespannt wie da unsere Kommentare zu ausfall.
Ja, sie haben gute Anwälte habe ich mir sagen lassen.
Gehe ich von aus, dass die gute an. Also so die Aktion ohne gute Anwälte durchzuführen, wäre auf jeden Fall Fall.
Also gute Anwälte und Unterstützung der Öffentlichkeit. Ich glaub da ist da kann man da schon was machen. War ja bei damals bei Landesverrat eben auch der Aufschrei der was gebracht hatte.
Landesfahrrad hat aber, ich will nochmal kurz auf diesen Aspekt der Stigmatisierung zurückgehen, der ist natürlich doch durchaus hier gegeben und,
landet die Landesfahrradsaffäre Umsetzpolitik Org war. Ich meine, der hat von Tagesschau, Chefredakteur äh Openian Peaces über im Prinzip die gesamte mediale Landschaft, wurde da,
gleichermaßen gesagt, das ist Journalismus und kein Landesverrat, da haben alle erkannt, dass sie bedroht sind. Ähm, ich bin mal gespannt, ob das jetzt in diesem Thema auch so ist, wie gesagt.
Ich hoffe doch, dass die Intendanten von Theatern sagen, ey, wir sind, wenn ihr die kriminalisiert, dann kriminalisiert ihr auch uns. Ne? Also das ist die, das muss doch die Reaktion sein. Also wenn die anfangen.
Sein. Wir haben sie jetzt noch nicht gesehen. Also ich bin also wir haben sie, ne, wir nehmen auf zu einem Zeitpunkt, wo wo diese Information noch nicht öffentlich ist, das heißt wir kennen keine Reaktionen.
Genau, ich, ich hoffe doch mal schwer. Äh, also bin, ja, ich denke, das wird ein Aufschrei geben. Mal gucken, das ist interessant, weil sie Hörerinnen und Hörer werden dann das merken, ob ob's einen gibt und wir wissen's doch nicht.
Es bleibt zu hoffen, dass hier die Verteidigung der Kunstfreiheit stattfindet.
So, damit wären wir bei einem nächsten Thema und zwar tatsächlich bei staatlichem Hacking. Ja? Ähm,
Und zwar gab es einen sehr interessanten Fall im Bereich der IT-Sicherheit in den letzten Tagen und Wochen und zwar meldete.
Dass äh Antivieren äh Scanner, Unternehmen Kaspersky. Ähm es habe auf dem auf den Rechner von insgesamt siebenundfünfzigtausend Kaspersky-Kunden eine Schadsoftware gefunden.
Diese Schadsoftware wurde bereitgestellt über das Asus live Update Utility.
Genau, äh das ist so ein Update, also Asus ist ein Taiwanesischer Hersteller von Computer. Ähm,
Ich glaube einer ist auf jeden Fall unter den Top Five, der weltweit umsatzstärksten oder oder verkaufsstärksten Computer. Ja, Hersteller.
Und wie das so so stelle ich mir das vor, wenn so Computer hat, dann hast du ja häufig auch so vom Hersteller nochmal irgendeine Software da drauf, sei das irgendein beschissener Druckertreiber oder,
nochmal ein Displaytreiber für irgendwelche Sonderknöpfe, die du an dem Computer hast oder so. Du kriegst ja allerhand schöne Software noch mitgeliefert, wenn du heute einen Computer kaufst, so, ne? Und ähm diese Software wird natürlich dann auch,
mit mit Updates versehen und dafür gibt es jetzt offenbar das Asos Live-Update Utility. Welches eben zwischen äh Juni und November zweitausendachtzehn.
Mit Updates versorgt wurde, die diese Schadsoftware enthielten. Ähm,
Das hat ähm Kaspersky eben festgestellt, ne? Ich meine klar, du stellst irgendwann fest, oder gibt's eine Schadsoftware? Wie ist die auf diesen Rechner gekommen? Wird Hals der Forellensick stellst fest, ah okay, beide. Die Katzpeski hat ja dann auch die Möglichkeit, auf ihre Kundenrechner ähm,
dazu Analyse zuzugreifen, stellt dann eben fest, okay, siebenundfünfzigtausend Leute sind damit infiziert, dann sagst du halt, okay, sammelt mal bitte die Meterdaten von dieser Software und dann siehst du halt in welchem Rahmen, in welchem Zeitrahmen die,
installiert wurde. Also sie stellen fest, zwischen Juni und November zweitausendachtzehn wurden die ausgeliefert. Casperski hat Asus am einunddreißigsten Januar,
über die offensichtlich Kompromittierung seines Servers und die nach Mywareauslieferung benachrichtigt. So, jetzt muss ich kurz ausholen. Wenn du.
Heutzutage verantwortungsbewusst Updates bereitstellst. Der Master ist natürlich hoffentlich über einen sicheren Kanal. Vor zehn, fünfzehn Jahren hättest du gesagt, na ja okay, Update liegt unter HTTP,
Update Punkt SIP, ja? Und da lädst du halt über über HTTP das Ding runter,
und jeder, der zwischendurch fragt, hätte der halt eine andere Datei untermogeln können und den Rechner hätte die dann ausgeführt. Heutzutage sagst du, ähm.
Erstens lädst du das halt dann über hattet die PS runter und noch viel wichtiger du signierst deine Softwareupdates. Was übrigens auch ein ähm großes Thema war im bei dem ähm Hack der Software PC Wahl,
weil wir darüber ja am Ende, nachdem wir den Webserver,
also Schwachstellen auf dem Webserver hatten und dort Dateien positionieren konnten, war das nächste Ziel,
dass wir quasi Updates bereitstellen können, die im Rahmen des Updates halt auch akzeptiert werden. Und äh selbst selbst PC-Wahl hatte einen eben nicht geeigneten, aber einen Schutz dagegen, dass beliebige Personen,
Updates bereitstellen. Ähm, dieser Schutz wurde umgangen, wie gesagt, wir haben's in Logbuchnetzpolitikfolge XY ähm ausführlich damals besprochen, wir haben's auch im Vorteil nochmal vorgestellt, Thorsten, Martin und ich und ähm,
Wir haben vor allem damals gesagt, die sinnvolle Methode so etwas zu machen ist, dass du die Updates selber signierst. Das heißt, die Datei, die dort liegt.
Wird mit eine,
mit einem mit einem mit einer kryptografischen Signatur versehen und dein Update hat, der die Datei herunterlädt, prüft, ob die Signatur stimmt, bevor er das Update dann,
anwendet. Ja? Und so hast du halt sichergestellt, dass dein
dass du im Prinzip auf unsicheren Kanälen auch potenziell die Software runterladen kannst, weil am Ende dein Update hast du sagt, wenn hier nur ein Bit dran anders ist und die Signatur nicht stimmt, dann führe ich dieses Update nicht aus
so kann dann eben dieser Update-Kanal, der sich erstmal der ja erstmal prädestiniert ist für die Infektion,
zum Ausnutzen eben dadurch schützt du dich davor. Jetzt war es so.
Dass diese Update-Datei, die dort statt äh die dort verteilt wurde, eine einerseits bereits drei Jahre alte echte Asos-Update-Datei war,
die infiziert worden war von wer auch immer der Angreifer ist und dann aber mit dem aktuellen Zertifikat von von Asus,
signiert wurde und deswegen haben alle Asusrechner diese Software heruntergeladen und sich infiziert, wenn man jetzt extra poliert von wie viele Asosrechner es gibt, ähm wie viel.
Viele Kunden sind.
Paar Sekunden sind, schätzt Kasperski ungefähr eine Million Infizitgeräte.
Und jetzt wird's aber, jetzt wird's interessant. Also erstens, okay, krass, so, du hast offenbar den Update-Server gehackt, du hast auch das Zertifikat gehackt mit dem Asos, die die Softwareupdate signiert. Und jetzt hat diese Software eine sehr interessante,
eigenartig Schadsoftware, die darüber verteilt wurde, nämlich das Erste, was sie macht ist, die nimmt die, guckt sich die Mac-Adresse des Rechners an,
Mac Adresse haben wir vor ein paar Folgen Lokbuchnetzpolitik erzählt, die im Prinzip äh einzigartige Hardware-Adresse der Netzwerkkarte, die in diesem Rechner sich befindet.
Hashtag und gleicht diesen Hash mit ähm einer äh mit einer in der Software gespeichert Liste von sechshundert Hashtags ab,
Und wenn dein Hash nicht da drin ist, dann legt sie sich einfach hin und macht nichts weiter. Wenn dein Hash aber dabei ist,
dann infiziert sie das Gerät mit einer weiteren Schadsoftware und royanisiert es dauerhaft. Und das heißt, wer auch immer hier,
Diese manipulierte Software auf eine Million Rechner gespielt hat es in Wirklichkeit auf nur sechshundert Zielpersonen abgesehen,
und wusste von den sechshundert Zielpersonen.
Dass sie einen Asus haben.
Dass die ersten Asos haben,
Und die Meckerisse aus der Meckadresse geht in der Regel hervor, dass es ein Asusrechner ist, also MacAdressenblöcke sind, also ich weiß nicht, ob Asus, eigene Mac,
hat aber äh die wussten auf jeden Fall, es ist ein Asusrechner und folgende sechshundert Mekker, du hast interessieren uns, die wollen wir infizieren, die wollen wir so dringend infizieren, dass wir sogar Asus dafür hätten.
Und potentiell eine Million äh oder neunhundertneunundneunzigtausendneunhundert nee dreihundert.
Ja, also sechshundert weniger.
Hundert weniger als eine Million ist. Ähm potentiell infizieren und das ist natürlich schon echt krass. So, das heißt, sie hatten
Sie haben im Prinzip Angriff Zugriff auf diesen Update-Server gehabt und wahrscheinlich irgendwie Teile der Asusinfrastruktur, um das dort zu positionieren. Und das erinnert an einen Angriff zweitausendsiebzehn,
wo das Gleiche mit der Software Cleaner gemacht wurde. Äh also auch so eine zweistufige, wo also erstmal geguckt wird, bist du Zielperson, wenn ja, dann,
Hier Staatstrojaner,
beziehungsweise von mir aus auch irgendein Trojaner. Ich meine, von mir aus waren das auch irgendwelche Kriminellen, die es ausgerechnet auf sechshundert Asusbesitzer abgesehen haben, aber das stinkt einfach schon sehr, sehr stark. Nach äh staatlichen Akteuren. Und äh ebenso zweitausendsiebzehn den Shadow,
Angriff, deren ähnlich, äh der also auch äh staatlichen Akteuren zugeordnet wird. Frage ist, welche staatlichen Akteure immer wieder schwer zu sagen.
Asus Verkauf weltweit. Deswegen wurde jetzt auch die äh Mac Adressliste,
Angriffsziele veröffentlicht. Und da bin ich mal sehr gespannt, weil jetzt natürlich zumindest die Zielpersonen wissen.
Wenn sie diese Prüfung durchführen, wenn sie also sagen, okay, habe ich eine der Mac-Adressen, die hier äh im im,
im Zielbereich war, dann wissen sie halt so okay, da hat's offenbar jemand auf uns abgesehen. Und es ist zu diesem Zeitpunkt zumindest noch unklar, wer das jetzt unbedingt ist. Also wer immer irgendwie spektakuliert, äh spektakuliert, spekuliert
Ähm aber das wird jetzt mal, das wird jetzt mal echt äh spannend. Und das zeigt eben.
Ich würde auf jeden Fall sagen, staatlicher Akteur, auf jeden Fall.
Na klar. Also ich meine, wenn es irgendwelche Cyberkriminellen waren, die hätten halt keine Zielliste, die würden halt einfach alle hacken.
Oder einfach warum warum machst du dir die Mühe irgendwie Asus Infrastruktur und das äh Software Signing, Surtifekit von denen zu kriegen, das aktuelle und und all das zu machen, um's am Ende nur auf sechshundert Leute abzusehen,
Ich meine, dass äh das Ding ist halt tatsächlich so, was machst du? Weil du sagst, wer,
also gehen wir mal davon aus, dass du irgendwelche besonderen Akteure, also auf besondere Akteure abziehst, dann weißt du, okay, wenn du einen höheren Sicherheitsstandard haben, dann werden die auf jeden Fall Updates machen.
Und vielleicht holen die sich ihre Updates ja von Asus. So immerhin benutzen sie ja Asus Rechner. Und dann wär's doch sinnvoll, wenn ähm,
wenn wir sie genau an diesem Moment angreifen. Man könnte also sagen, im Prinzip staatliche Akteure vergiften hier unser Trinkwasser.
Ja nun ist die Brunnen vergeben. Ding klein gutes.
Okay, aber.
Gutes Bild. Nee, klar, aber es ist.
Oder oder so greifen unsere Infrastruktur an. Ähm das greifen in das Vertrauensverhältnis ein mit unseren ähm das wir haben mit unseren äh Softwarelieferanten, mit unseren Software und Hardware-Lieferanten.
Und das ist äh tatsächlich übel. Das ist echt eine spannende Geschichte und das ist echt krasser Shit. So, was sagst du dazu.
IT-Sicherheit ist ja immer schon mein Spezialgebiet gewesen, also äh na, es ist ein, so ein, so ein extrem ausgefuchster äh äh Angriff oder sowas von den oder ist das.
Also ich würd's äh auf jeden Fall, also ich meine, am Ende wird man vielleicht rausfinden, wie die an dieser Asus Codeshining-Zertifikate bekommen sind, vielleicht lagen die einfach bei Asos auf dem Server rum, ne? Also,
hätten sie nicht, sollten sie nicht liegen, ne? Solche hast du halt. Genau, weil das eben wichtige Vertrauensanker in deinem Softwareup
Prozesse hast du dir eigentlich am besten auf irgendeiner äh auf irgendeinem offline Storage-Medium und,
hast du alles nicht gesehen, aber äh gut, da werden wahrscheinlich auch in Taiwan noch Fehler gemacht, aber so, ich meine, das ist nix, was du mal nebenbei machst,
Das ist nix, wo wo du sagst, ach ja geil, wir infizieren mal hier einen Update-Server, so. Ja, haben wir bei PC Wahl auch.
Welche sechshundert Leute du eigentlich überwachen willst oder.
Genau, du musst erstmal sechshundert Zielpersonen haben.
Sechshundert Zielpersonen finde ich schon ganz schön taffe Nummer, also so.
Bei Asus. Also ich meine, äh also okay, entweder geht's halt nur viel, man wissen, äh die haben alle Asus, wenn das so Industriespionagemäßig, könnte auch sein, also weil es ist ja so ein bisschen äh oder ich habe noch viel mehr Leute, die da im Fokus waren.
Also Kaspersky geht davon aus, dass Asus hier nicht ähm ähm Kenntnis hatte von diesem Angriff. Ich würde natürlich,
also zumindest diese Hypothese sollte man nicht ausschließen, weil du natürlich einiges sagen willst, okay ähm als Hersteller von Hardware,
würdest du im Prinzip genauso agieren, wenn dir jetzt jemand sagt, ja okay, passt auf, ähm hier
Cordor, ihr müsst jetzt hier ähm euch gegen eure Kunden wenden und die hacken, weil das sind ähm
wir verdächtigen die der Bildung einer kriminellen Vereinigung und dann würdest du halt sagen so, na ja okay, aber dann war bitte wenigstens zielgerichtet, gebt mal eine Liste der Mac-Adressen, die wir infizieren sollen, äh weil wir jetzt sicherlich nicht alle unsere Kunden für euch deppen infizieren und dann würde im Prinzip genau sowas dabei rauskommen
Gleichzeitig würde sowas aber auch dabei rauskommen, wenn du sagst, okay, wir haben zwar sechshundert Zielpersonen und der einzige Weg, wie wir die dran kriegen, ist irgendwie über Softwareupdates.
Aber ähm wir wollen natürlich nicht so viel Lärm machen, dass wir bei insgesamt einer Millionen Leuten potentiell in die Delektionsmechanismen geraten, also
machen wir es mal hier eine
kleinere Brötchen und sagen, wir limitieren das auf die Make-Adresse und weil wir die nicht äh verraten wollen, denken wir uns irgendein Hashing-Algorithmus aus und gleichen gegen den Hash ab, damit wenn die Marwe gefunden wird, nicht zu schnell herausgefunden werden kann in unserer eigenen Zielperson sind,
Das ist halt wieder so richtig schönes äh ähm Spyversus Spy, was hier stattfindet.
Na gut, ich sehe schon, äh wir nehmen das einfach nur als Messwert in dem im Bereich der des staatlichen Hackings ähm sehen, was für,
Aktionen dann auch offenbar von den einzelnen Akteuren hier ergriffen werden, haben keine Ahnung wer der, wer der Akteur ist, ich hoffe mal, dass dass wenigstens noch irgendwie im weiteren Verlauf rauskommt und muss natürlich auch anmerken,
Kaspersky, das sind die Idea irgendwie ähm von den Amerikanern und von den Europäern als äh irgendwie nicht vertrauenswürdig verunglimpft werden,
irgendwie gleichzeitig diejenigen, die Geschichten ausgehen. Die regelmäßig mit solchen Geschichten rauskommen, wo es irgendwie um staatliche Akteure geht.
Also ne, das ist schon auch äh so der liegt schon nah. Ne, ich meine, die haben der NSA Ärger gemacht. Die haben ähm hier jetzt wieder staatlichen aktuellen Ärger gemacht. Also ich würde mich jetzt schwer tun.
Privatpersonen unbedingt davon abzuraten, Kaspersky Produkte zu nutzen, weil die liefern wenigstens regelmäßig Tätigkeitsnachweise.
Na ja, aber ich benutze eh keinen Antivirus. Ich habe ja nichts zu verbergen und wer sollte schon? Wer sollte mich von der Bildung einer kriminellen Vereinigung.
Ja, das nächstes nächste Verfahren dann gegen den Chaos-Computerclub, also auch.
Wäre auch nicht das erste Mal. So, ein Thema, wir müssen mal langsam zu den positiven Nachrichten kommen.
Yeah, es ist was gewonnen worden, damit kriegt man nie Klicks auf Netzpolitik. Das ist,
Ja, die Überwachung hat mir letztens Meldung irgendwie Überwachung in Berlin, irgendwie das erste Mal seit seit zwanzig Jahren weniger Überwachung.
Liest keiner. So, geht nur wenn noch mehr Überwachung äh also es ist auch interessant, ne? Das ist also die Negativität äh die wir vorher angesprochen hatten, die geht auch da.
Die geht auch in die andere Richtung.
Also jetzt weghören in den E-Voting in der Schweiz wurde ausgesetzt.
Ja, das ist echt ein äh also das finde ich echt mal äh damit hätte ich nicht gerechnet. Wir haben ja diesen.
Introsionstest, den die Schweizer Post dann irgendwann in unter dem Druck der fortwährenden äh
Anti-Cyber-Voting-Kampagne in der Schweiz. Ähm
im Prinzip als PR-Aktion ausgerufen hat. Da haben wir im Prinzip gesagt, da macht nehmt ihr mal nicht dran teil, da kann man nur verlieren
ja? Weil egal was du da findest, sie werden es am Ende umdeuten in, ja, jetzt haben wir diese Schwachstelle beseitigt, jetzt haben wir diese Schwachstelle beseitigt, jetzt.
E-Voting sicher.
Jetzt ist das Cyber-Voting sicher, ja? Jetzt geht's, ja? Ähm,
und äh wir haben ja auch schon den den ersten Fund des Teams, um Sarah Jamie Luis äh vor ein paar Folgen diskutiert. Jetzt haben sie eine zweite Schwarzstelle gefunden, nämlich man konnte Stimmen ungültig erklären, ohne dass es auffällt, also die Schwachstellen, die,
sie findet oder die also die sie da äh veröffentlicht betreffen immer die Kryptographischen Implementierungen, Fehlannahmen in den kryptographischen Implementierungen die,
eigentlich ja die Integrität des Wahlergebnisses schützen sollen und damit verhindern sollen, dass Stimmen verändert werden können, ohne dass es auffällt, dass äh Stimmen ungültig erklärt werden können, ohne dass es auffällt und sie haben jetzt hier noch eine Schwachstelle gefunden.
Und ähm.
Wenn man sich die Wahl in der Türkei, die Kommunalwahl anschaut, wo dann oh jetzt zieht der CHP als CRP Oppositionspartei AKP vorbei, jetzt hören wir mal auf, äh, Ergebnisse in das Programm reinzuhol.
Ungültig. Fühlen sich hoch?
Ungültig hoch und oh hat doch die AKP gewonnen. Äh.
Genau diese Form von Schwachstellen, die man nicht haben will, ja? Ähm der Hersteller heißt äh Skytal oder Skit oder Skyte, ich weiß nicht, wie man das ausspricht und kommt, wenn ich mich nicht täusche aus Spanien.
Muss ich nochmal ganz kur.
Schnell.
Ja, genau, spanische Entwicklungspartner Skyte und,
Jetzt wurde mir auch klar, warum sich da äh international mehr für dieses System interessiert wird, weil das wurde auch schon in Australien eingesetzt und in der Schweiz eben auch.
Vier Kantonen. So, das alleine ist noch keine gute Nachricht, denn es wurden insgesamt im Verlauf dieses Inklusionstests
einhundertdreiundsiebzig Mängel im Quellkurt festgestellt und gemeldet
und Bundeskanzlei Kantone und Post haben sechzehn davon bestätigt. Das ist eine schlechte Nachricht, weil das heißt, dass sie den größeren Teil der Schwachstellen einfach ignoriert haben. Aber immerhin sagen sie jetzt
OK? Wir wollen den Quellcode korrigieren und von unabhängigen Experten erneut überprüfen lassen. Die altgenössische Abstimmung am neunzehnten Mai,
wird deshalb nicht.
Unter Anwendung dieses Evoting Systems stattfinden. Wir stellen das System dafür nicht zur Verfügung. Wir nehmen das jetzt, wir nehmen den Betrieb dieses Systems, setzen wir aus und das ist ehrlich gesagt ein ein Ausgang, den ich bei diesem ähm Pentest,
nicht erwartet habe,
Also ich habe eigentlich gedacht, die nehmen äh ziemlich genau, ne? Die was man wegdiskutieren kann, diskutiert man weg. Die sechzehn, die bleiben, da sagt man, jo, die bestätigen wir, die haben wir jetzt auch gefixt, jetzt ist alles gut. Äh jetzt können sie auch morgen noch äh beher.
Sicher wählen.
Können sie auch morgen noch sicher wählen und ähm und damit hat sich's. Das ist ein Ergebnis, mit dem ich nicht gerechnet habe, aber natürlich äh werden äh.
Ist noch nicht vom Tisch.
Das ist nicht vom Tisch, die werden dann natürlich nach diesem Aussetzen irgendwann zurückkommen und sagen, wir haben hundertsiebenunddreißig äh Mängel beseitigt, jetzt ist das System wirklich sicher. Jetzt findet auch äh Sarah Jamelo ist nichts mehr.
Von Sicherheitsexpertinnen äh.
Die werden sich halt auch hier wieder nicht.
Den fundamentalen Problemen widmen und diese Scheiße einfach sein lassen. Aber immerhin.
Etappensiege kommen ja nicht heraus, das ist immerhin einer und wir müssen die Etappensiege feiern, solange sie solange sie halten.
Das Papier. Okay.
Wir sind ja auch hier die die Bots der Papierindustrie feiern ihren Sieg.
Also das würde ich eh schon mal instrumentalisiert von der Papierindustrie gegen diese guten innovativen E-Voting-Systeme immer wieder. Okay, kommen wir zu den geht's weiter, zu den Kurzmeldungen, geht weiter.
Ja, wir machen noch eine Kurzmeldung, dass diese Kurzmeldung will ich noch kurz äh vorbringen,
einfach auch, weil diese Kurzmeldung für mich ein Live-Erlebnis war, ein Live-Erlebnis zwanzig neunzehn, denn ich war ja äh wie schon vor zwei Folgen berichtet, in Brüssel bei der EU-Kommission, bei dem EU-Parlament,
Ich war da live dabei als bekannt gegeben wurde, die Kartellrechtsstrafe gegen Google, ja?
Das waren oder ich habe mir noch nicht mit eins Komma vier neun Milliarden Euro Strafe wegen Missbrauchs einer marktbeherrschenden Stellung auf den Markt für Online-Werbung.
Ähm.
Locker nicht sein.
Kann man sich gar nicht vorstellen.
Haben sie gemacht.
Was haben sie gemacht? Ähm,
ist relativ kompliziert zu erklären. Ähm also sie bieten einen Dienst an, der heißt ätzend. Etzens ist im Prinzip die Werbeplattform von Google, dann kriegst du eben Werbung auf deiner Seite eingeblendet von Google.
Die sie an dem Kontext orientiert, früher war das ganz, also früher als das Internet noch gut war, da musste man nur irgendwas hinschreiben und dann hast du so Bürgerrechtstexte geschrieben und dann hat das fürs Gegenteil geworben. Also dann irgendwie,
Taser, lalala, gefährlichen Lebenden, Taserwerbung. Also es ist heute ein bisschen intelligenter wahrscheinlich.
Genau, also die, die vermischen quasi hier ihren Suchindex mit,
Wir haben eine wir blenden Werbung auf deiner Seite ein und dann können wir also Kontext gezielt, ne? Wir machen die Werbevermarktung für dich, du stellst ein paar Flächen auf deiner Seite bereit
wir wissen ja eh schon in welchem Kontext die Leute sind, was die gerade auf Google gesucht haben, ne,
interessieren sich für rosa Schüchen aus Glas. Also kriegen sie, wenn sie deine Seite besuchen, Werbung für rosa Schühchen aus Glas. Ich habe das auch einmal. Ich habe einmal irgendwie auf meinem Handy.
Den AdBlocker ausgehabt und da wird tatsächlich sogar äh so eine so eine Kaufprozess angestoßen.
Äh dann abgebrochen und dann irgendwie diesen Werbeblocker eine Zeit lang äh ausgehabt und ich war dann irgendwie, die wussten dann halt über mich nur eine Sache, für die ich mich interessiere.
Du willst diese Hose kaufen oder was.
Es war das war so ein ähm Seminar für IT-Security, was ich buchen wollte, so.
Also und dann hast du immer IT-Sek.
Nichts anderes, egal wo ich hingekommen bin, so, wollen sie nicht hier äh IT-Cecility-Seminar, ähnlich. Ähm.
Es ist interessant, wenn man den Adlocker ausmacht und dann sieht er, okay und da hast die Hose schon vor zwei Wochen gekauft, du bist immer noch so Retargeting. Hey, willst du nicht doch die Hose, du denkst doch, hey, verdammt, ich habe doch schon zwei bestellt.
Noch eine. Jetzt mach endlich neue Werbung.
Ja, das ist ja auch irgendwie so tagetmäßig irgendwie scheiße Retageding, also jetzt okay, egal.
Also dieses dieser Service, ja, dieser Service erzenzt, wo Google quasi seine geballtes Wissen über dich äh äh zur Anwendung bringt, um dir Werbung in den Kontexten anderer Seiten zu präsentieren. Ähm.
Da haben sie quasi den.
Die das benutzt haben. Gesagt, pass auf, wenn ihr Etzenskunden seid, dann dürft ihr ähm.
Eine Suchbox von Google auch benutzen. Also das das seht ihr auch häufiger bei Webseiten, dass die Webseitensuche selber von Google bereitgestellt wird. Serge Powered.
Zu sagen, dass äh Web-Publishing-Systeme immer Scheißsuchen haben und die eigenen Sachen nicht finden, weswegen Leute sagen, ah, da baue ich mir doch eine Google-Suche oben rein, was tatsächlich besser funktioniert, natürlich als diese äh.
Trupal suchen, zum Beispiel.
Oder äh suchen oder so, ja, Alter, aber es ist.
Okay und ach so und dann haben sie gesagt, haben sie verboten, ey, wenn du Lezenz machst hier, dann darfst du nicht die Suchbox von Bing reinmachen.
Wenn also die haben gesagt, wenn du diese Suche benutzt hast, ja, dann wurde dir Werbung eingeblendet und das Geld, was Google damit verdient hat, haben sie ähm sich geteilt mit den Webseiten Orner und sich selber, ja? Und dann haben sie gesagt.
Teilte.
Du darfst keine, wenn du Etzenskunde bist, darfst du keine andere Suchmaschine bei dir im Betten.
Haben sie irgendwann äh für einen Zeitraum ähm nicht erlaubt und für diesen Zeitraum, nämlich von zweitausendsechs bis zweitausendsechs bis zweitausendneunzehn.
Ähm,
Neun bis sechzehn. Nee, es gibt einmal von zweitausendsechs an und die haben diese Praxis mehrfach geändert. Also teilweise durfte es dann nicht, dann durftest du Rival Engines nicht benutzen. Jedenfalls,
sagen sie, damit haben sie quasi jetzt ihre gegenseitig ihre unterschiedlichen Marktbeherrschenden Stellungen ausgenutzt, um quasi ihr Werbekundengeschäft zu,
Stärkung ihres Suchgeschäftes zu nutzen und damit anderen Suchmaschinen den Marktzugang zu verwerten. Also wie gesagt, der Fall ist nicht so besonders hm,
einfach nachvollziehbar, ist ein komplexerer Fall, aber ähm es wurde dann eben errechnet, so eins Komma vier neun Milliarden äh Euro Strafen wegen Missbrauch einer Marktbeherrschenden Stellung,
dem Markt für Online-Werbung von der Kommission erlassen und wir haben weil wir ja gerade da bei der Kommission waren, haben wir dann auch nachher so ein paar Fragen gestellt. Würde sie so die erste Frage zahlen die dann auch? Und die Antwort des Mitarbeiters der Kommission war so oh ja.
Und ähm üblicherweise wird sowas wie dieses Geld dann über eine äh Bank äh Bankengarantie oder einen Closed-Account gegeben, wenn sie das, wenn sie einen äh Peel machen. Also die haben ja die Möglichkeit.
Gericht weiterzugehen.
Vor Gericht weiterzugehen, aber bevor sie das überhaupt machen, müssen sie auf jeden Fall das Geld schon mal auf so eine Art Treukinder Konterkonto geben, dann hat's weder die Kommission noch die ähm.
Noch Google, also das Geld fehlt denen jetzt sofort.
Na ja, sie zahlen sonst keine Steuern, also.
Genau, deswegen müssen wir die auf diese Weise eintreiben, finde ich total in Ordnung und ähm
Ähm dann wurde auch gesagt, was macht ihr mit dem Geld? Das wird dann tatsächlich an die Mitgliedsstaaten verteilt und zwar nach dem Schlüssel der Contributions. Also das, was die EU hat quasi einen Verteilungsschlüssel, wie viel du da reingeben musst.
Worüber sich die Briten hier so aufgeregt haben und wenn nach dem gleichen Schlüssel wird auch jetzt quasi hier der die Beute geteilt.
Fand ich mal ganz ganz interessant.
Ob Orban dann die Hand aufhält im Gegensatz bei den Geflüchteten.
Wir haben noch eine äh ja ist wahrscheinlich auch eine schlechte Nachricht. Facebook hat seit zweitausendzwölf hunderte Millionen Passwörter ähm unverschlüsselt auf ihren Servern gespeicher.
Ah, so macht man das, ne? Das ist IT-Security.
Das IT Security, ne? Besser äh so und ähm im Januar zweitausendneunzehn, sieben Jahre später ist bei einem Code Review herausgekommen, dass sie das tun.
Und jetzt werden sie äh umändern auf ähm auf gehaschte Passwörter und man muss noch nicht mal einen Reset dafür durchführen, weil sie gehen davon aus, dass äh die Passwörter über sieben Jahre lang äh da ja in sicherer Hand fahren,
und.
Genau, es ist niemand zu keiner Zeitpunkt, entstand ein Schaden für die Bevölkerung.
Kein Hinweis auf Missbrauch und sie haben dann noch, das finde ich sehr geil. Ähm der Titel ihres ihrer Pressemitteilung dazu ähm vom ein.
Passwort Secure. Das ist auch so was, was alle klicken, ne? Das ist auch so ein Ding so, ah ja, ich lasse mir jetzt nochmal erklären, wie ich mein Passwort eins, zwei, drei sicher halte, ne, haben sie jetzt irgendwie, ja, wir haben das falsch gemacht und sagen dann so, übrigens so ähm,
ändern sie ihr Passwort äh ähm in den Settings, suchen sie äh starke und komplexe Passwörter für alle ihre Accounts, äh nutzen sie einen Passwortmanager,
nutzen sie eventuell zwei Faktorautentifizierung. Die drehen das Ding noch um in so du musst dich besser schützen, ja? Und immerhin, sie sind ja auch das beste Beispiel dafür,
denn das ist ja der Grund, der Grund, warum man immer überall unterschiedliche Passwörter haben möchte, der Grund, warum man zwei Faktorauthentifizierung haben möchte,
Das ist unseriöse Anbieter gibt.
Das sind immer die ganz kleinen Anbieter nochmal, also das sind die uns die kleinen Webshop.
Die unseriösen Anbieter, die eure Passwörter einfach so speichern, die dir dann liegen, die gehackt werden und wenn das Passwort dann das eine Passwort gelegt ist, dann seid ihr überall dran. Und hier haben wir so ein unseriösen Anbieter. Facebook.
Also ähm ein weiteres Beispiel dafür, wie sehr man diesen äh unseriösen Anbieter vertrauen kann, nämlich überhaupt nicht. Und ähm entsprechend.
Wir haben ja so eine Bestenliste, ne? Also die, die ultimative Gesamtliste der Facebook-Skandale, ich weiß nicht, sie.
Timt, die hat er ja mal gemach.
Aber ich glaube, die sind schon wieder outdated, weil wir kommen nicht hinterher. Müssen da ein Redakteur insgesamt abstellen, damit das irgendwie aktuell gehalten werden kann. Ähm.
Das ist auch echt, das, sowas können die halt echt, äh, dass das bedauere ich auch wirklich, dass so so was, ja, da wittern, dann schreiben alle mal da drüber, ne? Aber so wirklich ein großes Ding war das nicht. Oder?
Was mit den Skandalen.
Hier, die ja Millionen Passwörter Unverstöße gesehen? Wollt ihr.
Nee, das ich glaube, ich glaube, dass die Leute auch mittlerweile einfach äh also so von mein Gefühl ist so so ah Facebook mal wieder irgendein Datenskandal, das ist so, das ist so diese Abstumpfung, ne, das ist genauso wie Innenminister will mehr Staatsruhe, mehr Überwachung, ist auch so.
Genauso wie wie A Klimawandel ähm mir ist kalt.
Ist gerade ein bisschen ist ein bisschen unter Druck, weil da irgendwie ein Schüler immerhin.
Die geben da Gas. Solidarität.
Die geben nicht. Solidarität.
Aber.
Mit Facebook oder was?
Nein, mit den mit den Schülerinnen und Schülern, die in Deutschland äh
protestieren und die Politik unter Druck setzen und einen Hebel gefunden haben. Dieses Thema, was aber echt über Jahre wirklich keine Sau äh ernsthaft äh wahrgenommen hat, hier ähm auf die Agenda gesetzt haben, großen Respekt für die Aktion.
Aber wir haben noch eine äh weitere abschließende, echt gute Nachricht. Das ist wirklich gute Nachricht.
Sehr gut. Ja.
Vanessa äh Rodel, um uns mal ganz äh ähm asozial nur Deutsch auszusprechen, weil ich's nicht weiß, wie man's ausspricht. Ähm die ähm,
ursprünglich von den Philippinen kommt,
eine sieben Jahre alte Tochter hat und in den letzten Jahren in Hongkong gelebt hat, dort versucht hat Asyl zu bekommen.
Aufgrund der politischen Verfolgung, der ihr, äh, die ihr auf den Philippinen angedienen ist, hat jetzt,
Am Montagabend ähm äh übergesetzt äh nach Kanada und hat äh Asyl in Kanada bekommen. Ähm.
Und das äh ist eine frohe Botschaft von Robert Tibo, dem Hongkonger Snowden Anwalt, der,
Snowden damals bei den Snowden Refugees zu denen Vanessa gehört versteckt hat und,
Wir haben ja auch hier regelmäßig darüber berichtet, dass die Snowden Refugees immer mehr Repression in Hongkong ausgesetzt wurden. Und jetzt tatsächlich wegen politischer Verfolgung,
in den Philippinen und Unsicherheit in Hongkong offenbar die hat die erste von ihnen ähm Asyl in Kanada bekommen und Robert,
fordert jetzt muss justin trodo vorwärts gehen und den anderen auch den Flüchtlingsstatus geben, sodass sie alle,
Kanada kommen können und dann endlich in Sicherheit sind. Und dem können wir uns da anschließen und wir haben hier Roberts Kampf über die Jahre sowohl auf dem äh CC-Kongress äh als auch hier im Logbuch immer wieder.
Verfolgt und darüber berichtet und können nur hoffen, dass diese wenigstens diese Geschichte ein Happy End findet.
Also auch hier herzlichen Dank an alle, die Roboter unterstützt haben. Wir haben ja auch von seinen finanziellen Problemen über die Jahre berichtet, da ja auch in Hongkong selber Repression ausgesetzt ist, die ihn dazu gebracht hat. Hongkong verlassen zu müssen.
Und da sind eben diese vielen kleinen Handlungen der Unterstützung und Zivilcourage wichtig.
Und damit sind wir am Ende der guten und schlechten Nachrichten. Hast du noch irgendwas zu sagen, was was deine Prognose.
Prognose für für die nächste Woche.
Was geht nächste Woche? Was nehmen sie uns nächste Woche weg.
Äh weißt du nicht, ich lasse mich da immer irgendwie überraschen.
Eine Wundertüte, die netzpolitische Wundertüte des Schreckens.
Haben wir nächste Woche auch bereit. Wir haben jetzt so ähm glaube ich relativ wenige Themen nur ausfallen lassen,
ob mit der mit dem Fokus auf Uploadfilter und ich danke dir Markus.
Gerne hier.
Dass du äh ähm unsere Hörerinnen und Hörer hier,
um deine Perspektiven und deine Meldungen bereichert hast, hier jetzt endlich mal die Möglichkeit ein ein Netzpolitik Scoop auch mal vor der Veröffentlichung aufzunehmen. Ich glaube diese Woche kommt noch einer. Ähm.
Ach so, ja, ja, da kommt noch was.
Wird noch was kommen, da reden wir dann nächste Woche drüber.
Genommen.
Vielen herzlichen Dank. Äh ich danke ja an am Ende der Sendung immer Personen, deren persönliche Unterstützung bei mir angekommen ist und das ist in dieser Woche der Bolko. Bolko ist auch ein cooler Name.
Also herzlichen Dank. Bolko und herzlichen Dank alle anderen, die uns hier so schön gewogen bleiben und übrigens auch in der letzten Sendung ähm uns sehr viel ähm einfach so moralische Unterstützung sucht. Das, was ihr macht, ist wichtig. Das hört man doch gern.
Also, ciao ciao.
Tschüss.